foreign
Treasure Trove for your website SEO or
search engine optimization holds the key
to skyrocketing your online presence by
strategically weaving in relevant
keywords throughout your website and
securing high quality backlinks you will
capture the attention of search engines
and soar up the ranking but SEO isn't
just about algorithms it's about
creating an exceptional user experience
from lightning fast loading speeds to
mobile friendly designs that Captivate
visitors SEO enhances every aspect of
your website with Rising technology and
exponential rise of websites on internet
there exists huge demands of SEO
professionals now talking about salary
and SEO professional at entry level can
earn salary ranging between forty five
thousand dollars to ninety thousand
dollars per year by gaining more
experience you can unlock higher
salaries in this domain so if you are
looking to buy become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply learns post graduate program in
digital marketing gain in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
with this course you will also learn
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and much more unlock a
whole toolbox of skills including SE
ranking HootSuite Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads and
Keyword Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course Link in the
description for more information here
stories from our satisfied Learners in
the
change is inevitable
is optional for me both came hand in
hand
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University when I shifted to
Dubai from Sri Lanka in 2015 I joined a
group of company as a software engineer
but my interest in content creation
attracted me towards the marketing
industry intrigued by the marketing
functions I decided to take up a
challenge that would change my life
forever I aimed for a career change as
risky as it was the rewards were truly
overwhelming even though the journey
wasn't easy the pgp in digital marketing
with photo University acted as not only
a catalyst but a game changer for my
career change with no profiling
certification in marketing domain it was
difficult for me to transition and
change my career towards completely
so I decided to upskill with the
professional certification program
I just simply learn because of its
tremendously High waiting to be rated as
one of the best Education portal online
worldwide is surely promising not only
were the ratings I but also the courses
were economically charged the modules
were very informative and amazing I
still refer to those while in the final
stage of my course I told my Superior
about the certification program I was
doing and then it offered me a digital
marketing role in the marketing
department as a digital marketing
executive is that's how smooth it was
after working for a few years in the
same company as a digital marketing
executive I switched to a new role as a
digital marketing manager with this my
skill upgraded my salary increase and my
self-confident Boost alongside numerous
other positive outcomes I had a chance
to take a challenge and change my career
domain all together
and I took it So currently I am pursuing
masters of Masters program from Simply
learn where I would complete eight
Masters program including artificial
intelligence cloud computing and devops
and many more growing roofers moving out
of our comfort zones
keep learning what is search engine
optimization
practice of getting traffic organically
through the search results with the help
of search engine is called search engine
optimization
although being one of the most important
components of digital marketing SEO has
had submits floating is the popularity
of your brand product or Services among
the audience thereby increasing the
chances of conversion of need to
customer
traffic obtained organically is more
consistent once you are aware of SEO
strategies and start gaining visibility
in search results your site will gain
constant traffic that will keep
increasing with time
with SEO one can reach a large audience
to promote products and services
businesses can acquire audiences from
both the national and international
levels
SEO builds trust among the audience for
instance if your web page is available
on Google search results the audience
finds it worthy of trust because of its
online presence
your competitors are doing it then you
should also do it this could be a
serious note if your competitors are
doing this to rank high and gain
visibility you must also do it or remain
back in the race
understand it with the help of an
analogy
Susan started a business of handmade
toys she failed to gain enough customers
using traditional marketing methods like
newspaper advertisements and banners so
she thought of putting the business
online thereby creating a website
the website was completely optimized for
search engines and was soon visible on
the search result pages
the website started acquiring the
traffic which ultimately became her
customers
the sales were boosted to an unexpected
level and the revenue has increased
exponentially
a good decision brought youth success to
Susan's business
Susan was thrilled with joy when a
thought struck across her mind
how was search engines able to find her
website
so search engines can be Google Bing
Yandex dub duggo Etc which work on three
basic steps
that are crawling indexing and ranking
first we will understand crawling
search engines are hungry for content
and so they send the Web spiders also
known as crawlers or robots a search
engine Bots to discover new content or
any updated content content can be an
image web page video or anything else
present on the web this process is known
as crawling
soon after the discovery of content
Web spiders start storing the URL of the
content into the search index and this
process is known as indexing once the
content is indexed it appears in the
search results for the relevant searches
when a user enters a search query the
most relevant search results are taken
from the index and displayed from most
relevant to least relevant on the search
result Pages this process is known as
ranking
search engine optimization is very very
complex so when you're trying to
understand it for the first time I find
it's very easy and best to just break it
into general concepts that you already
have some understanding of so when I
look at the hundreds of cons hundreds of
signals that go into SEO I break all of
them up into either relevancy and or
because sometimes it's both popularity
so relevancy popularity out of all these
signals they fit into one of these two
things throughout the rest of this
chapter in this course we're going to
break all the signals we have into these
two areas so that you can rely on what
you already know about the concept of
relevancy and the concept of popularity
to have some kind of Anchor Point for
these new brand these new ideas in this
section we're going to talk about the on
page factors and I'll tell you right up
front that these are going to become
your favorite these are the ones that
you have the most impact on and that you
can make a small tweak and have a
gigantic impact on the amount of organic
traffic that you send
start with one of my favorites title
tags title tags are the single most
important on page metric that we have
access to this is text that we get to
express that we get to write that shows
the intent and the purpose of that page
on the internet this is really really
important because search engines use
this this text that we get to provide in
their search results directly so we get
to write what becomes the headline of
the search result itself this uh in
addition to the meta description as
we'll cover next are the two factors
that we have a whole lot of control over
that influence both click-through rates
and people's first impressions of our
brand next up we have meta descriptions
now meterscriptions are a little bit
confusing because it is text that we get
to provide to search engines but more
often than not they override what we
provide and try to choose something that
is better in their opinion now I go both
ways with this sometimes it really is
better most the time though in my
opinion it's not but the important thing
here is that we get to provide what
would normally we'd have to pay for with
ad copy we get to provide it for free
customize it to however we want to
entice to entice clicks and the search
engines are happy to promote that and
show that in the search results
all right now we're getting into the
good nerdy stuff the header tags so this
was something that was built into HTML
when the web was first created the idea
here is that you're establishing a
hierarchy so you start with one H1
saying what the main purpose of the page
is and you start to break it into
subcategories so you'll have multiple
H2S below that multiple h3s between all
of that now H1s used to be a very
important and primary SEO metric that we
got to use but because it got abused it
now has less of an importance than it
used to so it shows what information is
less or more important than other
information on the page but it is no
longer the strongest indicator of what
is the most important page on that and
right now that's still title tags next
up we have URLs uniform resource
locators now these are the addresses of
web documents online just like you have
a street address for your house on the
internet we have URLs for any given
document anywhere it could be PDFs it
could be images it could be texting be
your homepage all of these have urls
these are extremely important for SEO
for a variety of reasons the most
important though is your keyword usage
you want to make sure that the words
that you're trying to rank for are
included in your urls the second part of
this ties in directly the first is you
want to keep these short so it's not
okay to just put a whole lot of words
you want to rank for in url you need to
remember that humans are the people are
the things that use the internet they
share URLs they try to say them over the
phone they do all these different things
where it becomes extremely important to
keep these short and succinct so that
people can easily share them and can
type them in their browser without any
issues
now that we've talked about the
importance of URLs let's talk about URL
structure let's dive in a little bit
here we'll start with domain name so
you've probably heard of this concept
before in the example with the URL I
have here example.com would be the
domain name so this is the first thing
that people see with your online
business this is what's going to mean
all your advertisements it can mean all
of your marketing efforts it's this name
right here I like to think of it in
terms of an offline world so if you're
walking around buildings typically look
like something so a barber shop almost
always looks like a barber shop a fast
food restaurant almost always looks like
a fast food restaurant that same idea is
going to apply to domain names if you
have a very spammy looking domain name
or one that's hard to spell or one
that's confusing people are going to
make an initial impression off of that
so make sure that you have something
there that's going to make a great first
impression it'd be something that's easy
to spell that one especially in this new
tech like Tech craziness that we live in
people do a terrible job of that but
it's something that's easy to spell and
something that's easy to pronounce and
easy to share
so how is this important to SEO well
keywords are why it's important to SEO
this comes up all the time it's
important to have keywords in your
domain name as long as you're not taking
it too far now this is one of the things
I go back and forth with people all the
time how do you know if you've gone too
far I don't know I mean if it looks like
you bought the domain name simply
because it has the keywords in it that
you needed then you've probably gone too
far but is that the best way of
measuring it can I take out my
calculator and actually calculate that
no you're just going to have to use your
gut you're gonna have to look at it from
a human from a human perspective so do
not go overboard keep it as short as
possible make sure it's something that
you can easily share something you'll be
able to put on your business cards and
be proud of not something that you
bought because you're doing it purely
for SEO reasons and you think you're
going to succeed okay so there's the
domain name now what about everything
after that so in this case it would be
this blog post that I wrote well that is
called subdirectories and you can
actually have in theory Unlimited
subdirectories but for an SEO
perspective you do not want to do that
and it's for all the reasons we've
talked about before if you have lots of
subdirectories it's going to be
confusing it's gonna be hard to share
it's going to cause lots of problems in
older browsers so your best practice
here is to keep as few subdirectories as
possible this will be good for both
robots and for human beings
with the subdirectories as well as the
files that come after them you want to
make sure you include your keywords so
again this is one of those weird things
where there's not a Quantified metric
for it but don't put the keywords in
there too many times but put them in
there just as as many times as you think
is absolutely necessary so generally
this is once or maybe twice if it's
already in the domain name okay that's
all the information I have right now on
URLs feel free to Google this subject if
you if you want to know more about it
because trust me there's a whole lot of
technical knowledge that goes into this
but if you're at this point you already
understand all the most important parts
of it
as you likely realize computers cannot
see images the same way that humans can
they do not have eyes and they do not
have the complex brains that we use to
get meaning out of pictures out of
pixels so because of that we've had to
come up with some other way of
expressing the meaning behind images
luckily the creators of the internet
were Forward Thinking and they provided
us with a factor called image alt text
alt text is the alternative text that is
shown when image can't load this is done
on purpose so that people who are blind
are able to extract meaning from
something when they can't see it this
worked out really well for search
engines because well they're effectively
effectively blind and so that they can
also use that information put into the
image alt text to understand the meaning
behind images
internal links so we have an entire
section on links but what I want to
cover at this point is just internal
links an internal link is a link that
points from your website back to a
different section of your own website
it's not pointing elsewhere and it's not
coming from elsewhere it's from your
website back to your own website this is
important from a relevance a relevancy
perspective you'll see internal links in
your main navigation when you'll have
one that likely says home one that might
say contact us or one that says about
what you're showing to search engines
and to humans is that this section that
if you click on this link will be about
our company or this will be a place
where you can find contact information
for us these links are not votes like
external links but they are relevancy
metrics that are extremely helpful
when a search engine crawls and
processes your website it doesn't simply
look for the instances of keywords it's
a lot more complex than that it's using
a technology called NLP natural language
processing what it's trying to do is
it's using algorithms to try to
understand the meaning of text the same
way humans do when they listen to other
people talk or read read text instead of
just looking for specific phrases or
like the order of words it tries to
extract what's behind that what is what
is trying to be expressed here emotion
feeling food anything so when a search
engine goes to your website it may see
keywords but it's looking for context to
them you may say just soccer but just
having the word soccer on your website
isn't going to help you rank
specifically for soccer what you need to
do and what is more common and actually
happens naturally is that you'll happen
to use words like goal and World Cup and
referee
Google and the other search engines are
going to take these into account and
understand what that you rank for soccer
or the Irrelevant for that kind of
keyword buy the usage of other synonyms
and other common words that are used
within the context of a bigger broader
idea the next on-site signal that we
have is site Maps now there's two kinds
of sitemaps there's the kind that are
for humans and there's the kinds that
are four robots or crawlers or spiders
the ones that are for humans are called
HTML sitemaps and you've probably seen
these before they're generally in the
footer of website click through it and
it shows you the major sections of a
website and usually provides some search
functionality those help you understand
as a human what the hierarchy of a
website is how does everything fit
together and how do I get to the to
something I'm looking for as quickly as
possible those are called HTML sitemaps
and like I said they're generally for
humans there's also something that
exists on the back end called an XML
sitemap now this is something you can
actually look at but it's formatted for
computers so it's not going to be easy
to read an XML sitemap uses a format
called XML as you can probably imagine
to show the hierarchy and the priority
of each of the URLs on your website so
that search engines can understand that
and figure out how everything is
interconnected
so this point we've covered a lot of
things that are important and things
that you should be doing and optimizing
now let's go the different direction and
cover things that you should not be
doing so these are the list of the most
common mistakes that I see that should
not be done for a well optimized page
the first one was keyword stuffing so
back in the day it used to be helpful
and again this is in the past it's not
true anymore it used to be helpful to
put lots of instances of the keyword
that you were trying to rank for on the
page search engines and humans for that
matter are a lot smarter about this now
than they used to be keyword stuffing
does not work you're not going to rank
better for any given phrase by including
100 times on the page so this is
something that doesn't work you should
not do anymore
next one is hidden text unfortunately I
still see this one all over the web this
is when you write content that is solely
for search engine it's not for people
and you'll put it say white text on a
white background so a search engine can
see this because they're a crawler
they're a machine but humans cannot
because they cannot see the difference
because there's no contrast
now that also used to work back in the
day but it does not and that is not a
useful thing to invest your time in
today search engines can tell when it's
white text on a white background that's
actually very easy to tell from a from a
computer science point of view
there's other ways of trying to hide
things but when you hide text modern
search engines are most certainly smart
enough to be able to figure that out
probably better than humans to be to be
honest so don't bother trying to hide
text just for search engines they're
going to figure it out and it's going to
work against you
next one is repetitive anchor text so
we've all read these articles where you
get to a page and it just doesn't feel
like it was written for people you're
reading a sentence and it's redundant
it's got lots of links in it that really
don't need to be links it's just it
confuses the way the flow of the
information on the page because you put
links when they're really they're not
necessary this also used to be a tactic
that used to work but is no longer
helpful search engines the natural
language processing algorithms they use
have advanced significantly so they can
tell when something is not readable when
something is probably intended for
machines and not for people so do not
waste your time on redundant links and
trying to trying to sculpt your page
rank or your your link Equity or the
value of links anyway like that because
just today's world it does not work
the last thing that we have on here is
cloaking cloaking is the idea of showing
one thing to search engines and
something entirely different to humans
now this is also like everything else on
this something that used to work but as
I mentioned before search engines have
their algorithms have gotten much
smarter and much more clever and they
can almost always figure out the
difference between when you're doing
this if you're showing one thing to
search engines and something else to
humans
with a with only a few exceptions that I
know of it which are in the process of
going out there's no reason to do this
so it is not something worth investing
your time in
now we've covered all the most important
on-page optimization factors let's take
a look at what the theoretical perfectly
optimized page would look like on the
internet now there's a big asterisk here
in that well no page would be perfectly
optimized because the internet's Dynamic
and fluid and things change all the time
but if there was one it would look very
eerily similar to what we're about to
talk about
let's start with the basics you need to
have a title tag the title tag needs to
have optimized keywords in it preferably
closer to the beginning of it and it
needs to be clear and enticing for users
to click remember this is what we're
going to actually see in search results
for most of the time for your search for
for the search result itself is you're
going to have this text here so a clear
and optimized title tag the next thing
is an enticing meta description now
remember meta description is not used
for ranking purposes but they are
tremendously important for
click-throughs so this is the this is
your chance to write copy this can
entice people to click through your
result rather than the other ones that
are going to be on the search result
page
after that we have a short optimized URL
so the important here thing here is it
needs to be short so it's easily
shareable so it's easy to understand
from a search engine perspective but it
also needs to contain the keywords that
you're trying to rank for so keep it
there keep it in plain English use the
phrases people are actually using to get
to your site but keep it as concise as
humanly possible now let's talk about
the page itself what does this actually
look like how are things structured
well the first thing you want to do is
you're going to want to make sure that
it is structured in the same way that
people expect to see websites meaning
there is a title at the Top If it's
appropriate there's some kind of
navigational elements around the site
there are pictures to make this worthy
of me to spend the five minutes of my
internet time grazing looking at your
content and you need to have text that
is well written and this all is very
hard to quantify but it's things that
you're going to just take a look at and
work with your team for things that are
interesting there's an attitude with the
page that has some kind of opinion it's
expressing information it's giving me
the answer to whatever question I may
have you need to make sure this content
at the end of the day is written for
humans this is something that I would
share with my best friend because I
think this is the single best source on
the Internet for whatever my information
need is at that moment
after that it needs to be bot accessible
so I actually see this problem all the
time with some of the major news
Publications the world they'll have a
really outstanding article or they'll
have a really beautiful photo gallery
but they've done it in a way where the
search engines can't see it which means
that on the Internet it's almost useless
which is which is a shame it's sad when
this happens
what you need to do is you need to make
sure that you have the world's best
content which is hard enough but you
also have to make it accessible to
search engines so this is certainly very
doable just to avoid Technologies like
flash and say Silverlight and use more
of these Open Standards like HTML5
that'll get you all the way there
the next one is social it needs to be
social it needs to be shareable so I had
mentioned the my when I'm trying to
create content that the bar that I tried
to rise to is that it is shareable for
my best friend well you need to
facilitate that sharing you need to have
some kind of way for them to actually
share it so this could be as simple as
adding the social sharing buttons or it
could be something as easy as enticing
them and giving them a call to action at
the end of the article to share it with
their friends or share it with people
who are important to them sharing on the
Internet is extremely important not just
for ethical reasons but for marketing
reasons for bottom line reasons so make
sure that you're facilitating that
the last one and it is certainly not the
least important one uh is Multi-Device
ready so I don't care if you use
adaptive design I don't care if you use
responsive design just make sure that
this content that you've spent so much
time crafting is going to work and is
going to be consumable easily on my
tablet and on my phone and on my
gigantic TV and all these other devices
so that when it comes time when you
finally earned that person coming to
your website to consume your really
wonderful content that they're able to
see it on whatever device it may be
holding so this is a general overview of
what a perfectly optimized website would
look like now remember this this is
going to shift depending on context but
make sure if you cover to cover all
these bases so that the signals that
we've all talked about make sense and
you have a real lasting impact with this
the two broad categories of ranking
signals are popularity and relevancy
of the on-page factors title tags are
the most important individual field
header tags are important but less so
than they were in the past
URL is important and should be semantic
alt text is important for search engine
as well as for blind humans
avoid keyword stuffing and Link
sculpting
you should always avoid keyword stuffing
hidden text repetitive anchor text and
cloaking
natural language processing is a
technology that aims to understand the
intent and semantic structure behind
text written by humans
keywords are the ideas or topics that
clearly describe what your content is
about
say for example here the title of the
slide is what is keyword research
so this is the keyword which suggests
that this slide contains the content
about keyword research
so basically
keyword research is a process of
identifying keywords or popular Search
terms that people tend to search for
when you identify relevant keywords all
you need to do is include these keywords
smartly into your content and this will
help your content to get higher rankings
and search results now the question
arises why does keyword research has so
much of importance and search engine
optimization
let's understand this
keyword research plays a major role in
driving traffic organically to your
website or your content
how does this exactly happens
when you select the most appropriate
keyword for your content there is an
opportunity where you can rank high in
search results by ranking higher there
are more chances that audience can
discover your content and reach to your
website
thus you get more and more consistent
traffic growth for your website
thereby indirectly promoting your
products and services
now that you are aware of how keyword
research holds importance
let's now see some essential types of
keywords that is long tail keywords and
short tail keywords so first we will
start with long tail keywords long tail
keywords are the keywords that are
mostly used to get more specific results
long tail keywords include keywords with
three or more words
for example shoes for a black dress now
coming to short tail keywords
short tail keywords are the general
keywords or most specifically General
Search terms short tail keywords include
one or two words in the keyword
for example shoes
now let's see the difference between
both the long tail and short tail
keywords by demonstrating let's go to
google.com
so now we are here to check the
difference between long tail keywords
and short tail keywords
so first we will check for the short
tail keyword
now suppose I am looking for the shoes
that should go perfectly with my
beautiful black dress
so here I add shoes
and see how the results are appearing
okay if you see the recommendations here
we get shoes for men shoes for women
shoes images shoe size chart
shows for rainy season
etc etc
and if I enter here
only shoes what are the results here I
get number of results from the shopping
websites
uh
with very number of shoes
with number of Brands and somewhere
locations of the shops
but none of the result is relevant
to what I am expecting that is the shoes
for my black dress okay so now
I'll just change
my search query I'll add a long tail
keyword here
and I will search your more specifically
for what I wanted
so here I'll add shoes for
black
dress okay
so here I am getting number of ideas the
image ideas in the search result that
what kind of shoes are going to go best
with my black dress
and here I'm getting several
combinations which I can wear with my
black dress so 12 best color shoes
here again I'm getting if we observe
clearly then all these results are
completely aligned to what exactly I am
looking for okay
and if I again change this query
more specific like shoes for black dress
for women
let's see what I get
so here I am getting more specific
results
in terms of movements
we will definitely understand how to use
long tail keywords or short tail
keywords during our research in the
upcoming part of this video Let's now
have a look on tools required for
carrying out keyword research
here I have got a small list of tools
that you will need to perform effective
keyword research so first we will begin
with Keyword Planner
Keyword Planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by Google some of
the important features of Keyword
Planner in clothes discovery of new
keywords
estimate monthly searches for a keyword
get the average cost of ads for the
keyword you are looking for and help to
organize keywords the next tool that we
have in our bucket is sem Rush
some important features of sem Rush
includes
helps to get competitor keywords data
it helps to get competitor backlinks
data finds competitors top performing
content
helps in getting competitors campaign
data
Etc
let me bring it to you notice that sem
Rush is one of the best platforms that
fulfill all your SEO needs
so do visit to semrush.com you can find
the link in the description box below
next tool that we have in our bucket is
RFS the free keyword generator tool by
RFS helps to discovered keyword ideas
helps in identifying the search volume
estimations
identify easy keywords for which you can
possibly rank for
helps you to get a list of long tail
keywords
and however it is not limited to Google
searches only Yes you heard it right
you can get keyword ideas for Google
Bing
YouTube
Yahoo
Etc now let's check another tool which
is Google Trends
Google Trend will come into action
during your keyword research when you
are looking for the top search queries
by users that is the most trending query
moreover you can check these details of
search queries
for your country for any other country
or even worldwide
not only this but you can also choose
the type of search for this query like
web search email search YouTube search
Etc
the next tool that we have is answer the
public tool
answer the public tool has free as well
as paid versions
this tool can prove a magic wand for
your business as it suggests the
questions that are asked by people in
your industry this can help you to
understand and create strategies for the
content that the users are searching
across the internet and the last tool
in our today's list is keyword tool dot
IO keyword tool dot IO has free as well
as paid versions in the section on
on-page optimization we talked about
factors that centered on relevancy in
this section we're going to go in a
different direction we're going to talk
about the signals that focus on
popularity so what does popularity mean
in this context well it's actually quite
simple popularity always relates to
links to hyperlinks on the web so you
have seen these when you see the
typically blue text that is underlined
what this is is a tool it's a ahref
technically in HTML that is pointing
from one web document to a different one
this is a pretty simple concept I
imagine you already know this
so what does this mean from an SEO
perspective well it turns out that this
gigantic group of signals the ones
related to hyperlinks are and are and
historically have been the Lion's Share
of signals that the search engines
process when trying to rank pages
now there's one big problem with these
from an SEO perspective is that they are
historically and today very difficult to
influence this is because they do not
take place on your website they take
place elsewhere it's other people who
are linking to you generally speaking
and this makes them very very difficult
to have an influence on so this is a
good thing and a bad thing it's a good
thing because it it turns out to be a
great metric for ranking web documents
it's a bad thing because it's hard for
us to make an impact on day-to-day level
hands down the most time consuming and
difficult part of SEO is link building
now there's a lot of reasons for this
primarily because it's constantly
changing and because of all the elements
that are involved with this but the big
the bigger takeaway here is that there's
no one-size-fits-all solution for link
building you have to take the context of
your business of your website and you
have to apply general principles to that
so in this video we're going to cover
these general principles so you can
figure out how to apply those to your
business
these principles are and I think these
are the most clever and the most
important ones are creating link worthy
content
proactively participate in an off-site
engagement and utilizing offline
relationships the tried and true method
for building links is creating content
that's optimized for humans so let me
explain what this means the currency of
the internet if you will is the content
itself that's why people go on they want
to read the newest article or they want
to see the newest video whatever it may
be that is what has been true since the
beginning and I have no doubt will be
true going forward so as an SEO or as an
online marketer in general you can use
this to your advantage creating the
content that people are going to want to
share with their friends or that they're
going to want to cite in any kind of
paper or whatever they're working on
that is a tried and true way of gaining
links this is what we call the power of
content you can do all kinds of bells
and whistles you can go do these newest
tactics you can try all these different
things out but at the end of the day
what's really important is the content
itself so this is what I focus on this
is where 80 of my time goes on when I'm
working on link building it's on the
content itself can I create something
that is just truly that is so truly
great that someone essentially has to
link to it this is what I focus on
trying to answer and while there is no
simple answer to that go and ask that
question always sets you in the right
direction
the next strategy that I want to talk
about is actually very counter-intuitive
so if you're trying to build links to
your own website I found one of the most
effective ways and this is consistently
true is to engage off your own site now
this doesn't make any sense right why
would you work on other people's
websites if you're trying to promote
your yourself well think about human
beings human beings are much more likely
to link and give back to people to human
beings that they know well so a lot of
the time I spend when I'm doing link
building is spent off-site engaging with
others so sometimes this is through
social media so I'll use whatever the
latest social network is and I'll chat
with people there who have similar
interests or have similar interests to
what I'm trying to promote be it a
different topic or be it a new industry
all together I'll spend a lot of time
promoting others and a lot of times
chatting with other people building up
genuine real relationships with human
beings so that when it comes time for
them to write an article or when it's
when they're ready to link out to other
people I'm the first person they think
too and they link back to my website one
of the reasons that link building is so
hard is because the internet moves so
fast what worked yesterday might not
work tomorrow
so one of the most clever and easy ways
to avoid this problem is to just simply
go offline utilize some of the
relationships that you have off of the
internet in order to benefit on the
internet this is something I try to do
all the time because it consistently
works by far the easiest favors to cash
in on are the ones that you already owed
so these might be from your friends who
you work with who might be from friends
who from childhood these are people who
you actually know in the real world who
are much more likely to help you when
you're trying to promote new content
online
so what I'm trying to do link building
one of the things I focus on is people
that I know in the real world
so this can be lots of things this can
be personal friends who happen to have
websites and blogs this can be friendly
competition you have or friendly allies
you have in your space just saying hey
we're looking for these kind of things
can you help us out maybe I'll help you
out somewhere else it's utilizing these
relationships that Exist Elsewhere so
that you can start gaining these links
yourself
if that doesn't work if maybe you don't
have any friends in these Arenas you can
always go to local businesses and local
agencies so sometimes this is a
government-owned thing sometimes this is
just third parties all together
there's lots of things that they need
help with that you as a business owner
or you as uh trying to promote some
client may be able to help them with and
if you can help them offline they're
more much more likely to help you online
well link building it's very important
to understand that not all links are are
created equally a link coming from the
home page of CNN is going to provide a
lot of what we call link Equity it's
going to have a lot of popularity
metrics tied to it and so it's going to
be more valuable to you and help you
rank higher whereas a link also coming
from the home page but let's say Joe's
spam blog that is not going to be
particularly helpful for you and it
actually in some cases could hurt you so
when you're going out and doing link
building make sure that you can stand
behind the source of the link that is
coming at you this could be in a good
example from like a government website
where it's trusted and a bad example
this could be from a website that you
would not normally go to even on your
own
in addition to that there's different
kinds of links depending on the
direction that they're going so if a
link is coming towards you towards your
website that's called an inbound link
these are the ones that are very helpful
for popularity metrics that we've talked
about
there's also outbound links these are
links that you linking to other people
now generally there's a big
misconception about this that you'd
think you would not want to link out to
other people but if you just follow the
natural chain of events and you look at
people who are writing blogs without SEO
in mind you'll see that they are linking
out naturally and it's these natural
patterns that search engines are looking
for so there's absolutely no problem in
linking out just as long as it's two
sources that you actually do trust so
there's inbound links there's outbound
links there's links that have a lot of
popularity value so like from an
established Government website or from
something popular like CNN there's also
links that are inbound that are not
going to have as much value for you that
you probably don't want to spend your
time building now regardless of where
your links are coming from it's
important to look out for one particular
attribute it's called Rel nofollow Rel
no follow was a tool that was originally
developed to combat comment spam like on
blogs you'd have lots of people who are
leaving
completely irrelevant comments so they
could link back to their own website and
get credit for that that does not work
at all today one of the primary reasons
for that is the search engine introduced
something called Rel nofollow where they
said here's a link that's going out for
my website but do not stand behind it
and it does not pass any credit a lot of
times when you're doing leak building
you'll get a link which you're very
proud of coming from somewhere very
popular but then realize that it has
this attribute attached to it no follow
and which means you will not get any
credit for it so make sure that when
you're doing your leak building the link
coming at you that you've earned does
not have this attribute associated with
it otherwise you will get no credit for
it now that you understand what nofollow
is let's let's talk about the biggest
use case for this social media most of
the links that we see in social media
are valueless this is because they're
either hidden from search engines
entirely this mostly happens on Facebook
or they're visible to search engines but
they use this row this Rel nofollow
attribute which means that they're
useless so while social media does have
many many benefits SEO and particularly
link value from SEO is not one of the
direct benefits of participating in
social media now that we've covered some
of the link building dues let's talk
about some of the link building don'ts
so these are the things that you should
not do because you'll be wasting your
time and possibly more importantly your
money the first one is Spam so we have
all seen this online when you go
somewhere and you see just a bunch of
spammy links links that are clearly
written only for machines only for
search engines a lot of times these will
have the name of pharmaceutical drugs on
them a lot of times they'll have um just
can be completely irrelevant to the
content
while these have worked in some
instances they are certainly not a best
practice and they are certainly not a
long-term strategy so I never recommend
trying to invest in spammy links this
way because it's not going to ultimately
help you in fact in many ways it'll
probably hurt you so do not go out of
your way to try to get spammy links
the next one is buying links this is
these are toes closely tied together now
buying links is when you go out and try
to buy sometimes relevant sometimes
irrelevant links and again this is
something that had it worked sometimes
historically not always my biggest
problem with this is not so much the
ethical problem although there is one
there the search engines of clue said
not to ever do this my biggest problem
with it is that you cannot calculate an
accurate Roi on this so if you spend a
dollar on this you don't know if you're
gonna make a dollar or two dollars back
you have no idea there's no way to
accurately measure this so you have no
idea if this if this is valuable to you
or not
where as opposed to if you're creating
valuable content you can measure that
and you can directly tie it to Sales so
your your money dollar for dollar is
spent much much more effectively on
content than it is on buying links so I
highly recommend do not spend your time
or your money buying links
the last one is acquiring reciprocal
links so reciprocal links as you can
imagine are links that go in a circle
you link to somebody and they link
directly back to you now in the natural
web when no marketing is taken to place
into this there's no kind of
manipulation trying to go on that
happens that happens all the time so
don't go out of your way and be afraid
of this happening so one new site will
very regularly link to another news
article and that article might link back
to them somewhere else that happens so
don't stress about this too much but
don't go out of your way to try to build
all of your links in a reciprocal way
we're overthinking this by trying to
link to somebody else who links to a
third party that third party links for
you don't waste your time this is just
not a factor that you should worry about
reciprocal links are not generally as
good as one-way links but it happens so
often that is not is not worthy of your
time or any kind of investment trying to
avoid this so
to become
and then simply learns post graduate
program in digital marketing gain
in-depth knowledge of search engine
optimization with this course you will
also learn content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website optimization and much
more unlock a whole toolbox of skills
including SE ranking HootSuite Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads and Keyword Planner don't
miss out on this opportunity Find the
course Link in the description for more
information
foreign
the concept of linking is foundational
to good rankings and understanding the
internet at Large
it starts with the premise that good
content will be cited by others
recommending it to other people
how we cite and recommend information
online is by linking to it
we link to information that we find
valuable
based on that the search engines assess
content by how websites link to one
another
so we are going to cover the definition
and purpose of links and the different
functions that links serve
we'll also look at how links mirror
human judgment
we'll look at how search engines
evaluate links by mirroring human
judgment
and how that affects what's called Block
Level analysis
and how where the location of different
links and how they are used will greatly
affect their relevance
we're going to look at how visitors from
different link sources will behave
differently based on where they came
from
and also how you can measure the
effectiveness of links and finally we're
going to look at both good and bad
linking practices now links serve a
number of purposes
from a functional standpoint they
usually are our primary means of
navigation online we click on links we
go to different pages and from those
pages we find links to other pages
links are also a method of citing other
content
when we quote somebody when we use
information that we have found somewhere
else we cite that information to give
credit to the original author
typically online we do that with a link
so that if someone wants to see the
original Source document it's available
to them that also helps to provide
credibility to you
credibility to the author of the
original source as well as assigning
importance to the knowledge that came
from that original source and the
authority of the original source
links also provide us with a clear
structure of how our websites are built
how the pages relate to one another and
how organized the information can be
so let's break down the functional part
of a link
this is important if you're going to be
developing anchor text and linking to
understand the structure
the ahref equals is the start of the
link tag
what you are doing is developing the
reference of where the document is
contained that's the href reference is
what it is short for
what comes next within the quotes is the
location of the document now this can be
a full URL or you may just be linking to
a document that's on the main root level
of your server
this is the full location where you can
access the document
and so you're putting the name of the
document the extension so that it will
be linked
the next part is what I have in caps
you'll notice off to the left I have
something in all blue text and
underlined which most people will
recognize as a link
you see when it is in between the
document location
in the closing of the link tag the text
you have in there is what's called
anchor text
you see instead of publishing the
document location and the full URL of
the document
we can put the link within text and
create anchor text so all someone has to
do is click on the link and the document
loads for them
this anchor text is vitally important to
understanding how we can add additional
relevance to linking content
then we see the closure of the link tag
this is what makes the internet the
internet is millions of pages connected
together by Links
so when we look at the functional side
of links and we look at this example
here as you can see the title of this
article is not the URL address of the
article it's a title and the title is
the link that is the anchor text of the
link
and so from a search engine standpoint
search engines look to see what words
are being used in the link and how
relevant those words are to the document
that is being linked
it also looks to see where is the link
is it in the editorial information in
the article
is it part of the navigation
is it in a sidebar or is it an ad
and then also search engines are looking
to see if this is a text link or an
image link
how long has that link been there
what type of link is it
does it go somewhere within your website
does it go to another website or is it a
reciprocal link which I will explain
more later
they also look to see the text in the
link and the context to the page with
the link directs you to
we utilize links a little differently
you see from a human standpoint whenever
we refer information to another person
when we provide reference material to
another person or even if someone asks
us for a recommendation we provide this
information
you see offline we mirror the same
behavior as we do online when we link
people ask us for information and we
provide it
we just mirror that online by making a
link
offline we recommend we refer we provide
information to each other in much the
same way the way I want you to think
about it from a human standpoint is that
if you asked another person for advice
or directions or a referral
are there certain people that you would
trust more than others
I'm sure the answer to that is yes and
maybe you have some people in mind that
you are thinking about
you see we run across the same issue
with search
the search engines know that there are
some websites that are much more
trustworthy than others
just like if you were to ask someone for
information I'm sure you would ask the
right person
for the information you would ask the
most knowledgeable trustworthy person
you knew
who had Authority in that subject area
the search engines are trying to do the
same thing with the links that we
publish on our websites they're trying
to determine who is the most trustworthy
and relevant based on the
recommendations referrals and citations
of other websites to other websites
who are the websites that are trusted
that are authorities
the search engines are trying to do from
a technical algorithmic standpoint what
we do naturally from a human standpoint
now from The Human Side as I had said
before we need to think of links as
information that we receive from other
people
Word of Mouth advice information
directions recommendations this is where
we need to think about links not from
the standpoint of building false
relevance for a search engine but being
a helpful resource for our readers how
can we help them how can we provide
information and how can we be a credible
source of information
how can we develop our Authority within
the industry and so that people who have
questions about this content will see
our websites as authoritative and
credible resources
the best way to develop links as you'll
see is good content when people like
what they read when they like what they
see when they are willing to recommend
it to others it's because you have
created something of value
and they'll link to you when they feel
that you are credible
and that you are authoritative with this
information
only then will they share it with other
people
because you have earned that right for
them to share it with others by
providing content that is informative
educational entertaining and you've
provided that service only then will
people then want to recommend it to
others by linking to it
now links serve a number of benefits
When I look at some of the incoming
links to my site one of the things I
notice is that if I get a link in
certain places that can drive a lot of
brand exposure I can have thousands of
people coming to the site looking to see
an article and that provides a lot of
exposure to a lot of people
however also getting a link from a
certain website especially if it's a
high relevant authoritative website I
can see my rankings increase because of
that
but then also a good link is going to
drive people that will convert and drive
sales or leads those who become
customers
so those are the three aspects of a good
link a good link will drive traffic to
your site a good link will assist your
rankings
and a good link will bring in business
if you can get a link to do all three of
those at the same time that's what I
call the golden link because it has all
three benefits
usually however you're going to find
that different links will provide
different types of benefits one of these
three or maybe two out of these three
one of the things I'm usually very
focused on is the link that drives sales
or generates leads that's getting links
in the right place that will benefit me
tangibly rather than just getting
thousands of people to see it
why it benefits me financially if I can
get a link in the right place
so from here let's break down the
different types of links
we have navigational links we see these
in our navigation our primary navigation
maybe the footer of our web pages where
we have links to typical information
such as about us or contact us
we also have sidebar links this might be
related information or offers or calls
to action
and then also I would break it down into
outbound or inbound type of navigation
outbound are links going to other
websites inbound links are links that
come from other websites and that also I
might send to other pages on my own site
now I've used the term editorial an
editorial link is a link that is found
within the content of the website
and by that I mean through an article
so if I am writing an article and I link
to someone else and cite them or
reference them
that is what's called an editorial link
it means that it's part of the content
a great example of this is that the
navigation on your web pages is not part
of the content
it serves a function as navigation
but it doesn't have anything to do with
supporting information with citing an
authority so information and links that
you put within the content and presented
content of your site are considered
editorial
now there's also call to action links
where you're bringing someone to a
landing page or a registration page or a
sale page
then also we have Social Links now these
can provide a variety of means but
typically a social link will go to a
profile
maybe it's a username that takes you
somewhere else or comment or maybe just
an image or something that goes to a
social site or that you have placed on
your own site as well
either way it's all contained within
that social network even though the
links are going on and off your site
they tend to be controlled in that
social environment
now I've used the term reciprocal link
now this is
something very specific
a reciprocal link is one where you would
go to somebody else and you would make a
trade such as if you link to me I'll
link to you and maybe you put those
links on the home page or maybe you
create a page just for that link
you see sometimes it just doesn't make
sense and so the search engines will see
that you've linked to each other but if
there's no contextual relevance if
there's no contextual relevance
most likely you won't get any benefit
because you've agreed to link to each
other for the primary purpose of
boosting rankings
now this is not to say that two websites
can't link to each other because there
is some relevance
we'll look at some examples of that
later on in this module
also then we have advertising links
these can be ads banners anything on the
page that is an advertising link that if
you were to click on it you would go to
that advertisers page
those links are typically through an ad
server and they take place in entirely
different ecosystem
but they are links and we need to know
what kind of links are advertising and
which kind of links are functional to
our websites
now when I broke down the different
types of links so we have our navigation
links we have links in our sidebar and
in our footer
with Block Level analysis does is that
the search engines look at the code of
the page
they break down the page because it's
very easy to figure out which part of
the code has to do with your navigation
which part of the code has to do with
your sidebar and your footer and which
part of the code is calling ads from an
ad server what this leaves is the
editorial content your article and the
ability of search engines then to break
down your page into these different
elements the reason why they do it is
that the links contained in the
editorial space are considered to be
more relevant in terms of linking to
other websites than any of the other
types of links on your web page search
engines don't consider all parts of the
page to be equally relevant which is
okay because neither do humans we look
at the navigation as utilization pure
utility because it's just helping me
navigate among the different pages of
your website I'm not expecting to learn
anything I'm using it as a functional
means of navigating your site now your
sidebar might have some calls to action
might have links to other pages but it's
not an article it's what you've
developed and so it might be a little
more important than your navigation but
it's not as important as what you may
have written within content your footer
navigation is basically the same you
control that it's the same on every page
and so what the search engines are
looking for are the unique content
the unique article or information that
you've published and if there is a link
within the editorial content that is
highly relevant because it has to do
with content it has to do with
information that you are sharing
and so the links there are going to be
more highly relevant and are going to be
more important for the search engines to
see
you see it's the same way with humans
we're not going to look at navigation to
learn something it's functional the same
thing with the footer and as humans
we're reading the content that you have
in your article and if you link to
another source well you've provided us
with utility but it's contextual utility
because you're citing where you found
information or you're citing an
additional Source or you are linking to
an example and it enables me as a human
to see that understand it and if I need
that additional information I can click
on it and go to it
so I'm going to look at the information
on the page in that article very
differently that I'm going to look at
the headings the navigation the sidebars
or the footer because the article is
what is informing me and so the links in
the article I'm going to look at very
differently and hold them in a higher
level of relevance
now over time search engines have had to
refine the algorithm about links
you see in the early days of search
engine algorithms they used to Simply
count the amount of links than if one
site had more links than another that
made it more credible
however once people started to figure
that out people started accumulating
links by really any means necessary
and they were just looking for the sheer
volume of links because they knew if
they got the most amount of links it
would affect their rankings
and so over the years the search engines
have had to change and adjust and add
more relevance to their algorithm
refine it in order to look at different
aspects of links in order to properly
determine relevance
so over time it wasn't just having a
link it was then also looking at how
many people cite this site as an
authority so looking at the source of
the link and the types of pages
then also looking at the text of the
link and matching it with the text of
the page
does it match is it contextual
and then looking at the type of Link
doing the Block Level analysis
and then also the context the relevancy
of your site compared to the linking
site compared to the link and the
information that's being shared there
also some of the ways that they can look
at it at the age of the link how long
has that link been there
humans do the same thing when we look to
see how long someone has been in
business we're looking at credibility
and then of course there are many many
other ongoing refinements that are going
into the search engines evaluations of
links sometimes the age of the link
isn't as relevant especially when you're
looking for something that has happened
very recently
an Old Link could mean that it's old
news or that something has changed since
then
so search engines are in a constant
battle to ensure that people are not
gaming the system
by falsely creating relevance through
linking
the link relevancy and the algorithm is
all about trying to determine who is the
most relevant and credible within this
area
and that is the focus of most search
engine algorithm refinements over the
past few years and it will be into the
future
now this is where I'm going to start
bringing in some screenshots from a link
Management program
as a search engine Optimizer a link
Management program is probably going to
be one of your best friends as you move
along in this industry
in this example this program link Decks
that I'm using will track the incoming
links to my website and it'll also
provide a breakdown as to what type of
website those links are coming from so I
can see how many links I have from blogs
how many links I have from news sites
how many links from wikis how many links
from directories forums social media
public relations sites articles or
additional resources
then I can also add my competitors and I
can compare where I stand in terms of
the amount of links from each source and
where my competitors stand
in this way I can be sure that we all
have a similar link profile you see if
my linking profile looks vastly
different than all my competitors the
search engines are going to see that as
well and know that something might be
different with me good or bad and that's
going to raise a red flag
so I want to look at the linking profile
because every industry and
almost every business is linking profile
is going to be a little different but
especially among Industries we see that
linking profiles that is the amount of
links from different sources it's going
to be slightly different for every
different type of industry or business
so this helps me understand where my
links are coming from which is vitally
important because from a business
standpoint one thing that I've tracked
consistently in analytics is that people
will act differently and also I can
predict which source is going to send me
the best customers
you see just because someone comes from
a link doesn't mean they're going to buy
or become a customer or really become a
lead
many times they're going to come look at
your information and leave
and based on how they come to your site
whether it's through a Blog a directory
a forum or a new site has a lot to do
with how they view your website
and it's all about the context
you see this is what I've learned over
the years is that people will behave
differently based on how they find the
website
what I found is that people from blogs
news sites and articles they tend to
stay longer do more and have a higher
chance of conversion of becoming a
customer or a lead
the main reason is because blogs and
articles they have a lot of context it's
an article someone has taken the time to
write some information out and then link
to my site which means there is a highly
contextual reason for someone to click
that link
also what it means is that there's a lot
less competition for that link when my
link is in that article
compare that with social news or any
type of social site
you see when you're on a social site and
you're looking at your social stream of
information there's a lot of different
people competing for your attention a
lot of different things and it's not
just in one subject area it's usually
from multiple subject areas and so the
context is very low because there's a
lot of different types of information
and the competition for your attention
is very high
because of that people from social sites
or applications
tend to visit more often but they only
tend to view one page and leave
immediately
because they're looking to see what was
interesting and then they move on to the
next subject
that's the difference between how people
react based on where they come from
and so when I'm measuring links I'm
looking to see which links do I have
what's the source and then how do those
sources behave differently from one
another
and why
you see if I find that I'm getting links
from sources that people are staying
longer doing more and converting at a
higher rate then I'm going to continue
to focus on building links in those
areas because it directly affects how I
monetize my website
so here's a strategy in building links
one of the things I'm looking at is the
source of links like I said if I can
find a link Source that's providing
visitors that will stay look at my
content engage with the content and
eventually convert and convert at a
higher rate than other sources of
content or visitors
then I'm going to focus on that source
and so I'm going to look at some high
Authority websites whether they're
industry Publications news sites
education sites those are what are
considered high Authority
blogs articles news sites
that's what I'm looking to do I want to
find the most authoritative website
and sometimes it happens naturally if
people that work at those websites or
manage those sites if they find you and
they like your content they'll link to
it and that way you can get more
credibility more relevancy
certain people certain organizations
certain websites have more Authority
influence than others it goes back to
the question that I asked you early in
this module that how do you know if
someone is more authoritative than
somebody else
we also have mid Authority websites
which you can get some links on and low
Authority websites which are very easy
to get links but here's what I've
learned when it comes to link building
one link from one high quality website
can be worth hundreds or thousands of
mid to low quality links
ultimately it's about quality not
quantity
one of the things that I will do
utilizing my link software is look at
the context of the link
I want to see how relevant this is so as
I said if I want to find a high relevant
website what I'm looking for in terms of
this is I want to see the influence of
the domain as well as the relevance of
the domain those are two factors that
we're going to look at when we're
evaluating the quality of a domain now
as I'm looking at this report here what
influence means is that it is a high
quality website
that within the linking algorithm these
sites have a lot of authority however
they may not be relevant
so for example they may have a lot of
sites attributing authority to them
but they may not be relevant to my
industry which is why we have the next
column of keyword relevance
you see when I'm evaluating my links I'm
looking for the sources that are both
influential and relevant
that means that I've got a link from a
site that fits the two standards of high
Authority it's authoritative and
relevant now it's good to have links
from authoritative sites that might not
be relevant
it's still authoritative
however to get the full benefit I want
it to be influential and relevant but
not to say that I'm not looking for
links from these other sources this is
just a means of measuring what you have
as well as comparing it to your
competitors and other websites
now here's some best practices when I'm
optimizing anchor text I want to
maintain contextual relevance so I want
to use text in the text link and I want
to explain to people what they're
linking to what they're going to find
when they click on that link if I use an
image as a link I'm going to use an ALT
attribute because if that image doesn't
show up
that ultrabute
is necessary to let people know where to
go
but also I do get a little tiny bit of
benefit by using that alt attribute
within the image link
I also want to look at the relevance of
the source page that I'm linking to and
make sure contextually the link the link
text and the content of the page is
contextually relevant to the destination
page
I also want to be sure that I don't
overuse the keywords that I don't make
multiple links to the same destination
that I don't use the same anchor text
over and over
I can be downgraded or even penalized by
the search engine algorithm if that is
found on my pages
so as an example instead of using click
here
for a how-to article
I might use the exact phrase of how to
fix whatever it is and use that as the
link to the page that has the content
that's a simple way of looking at anchor
text am I directing someone to
additional information if I am then how
can I present it to them so they know
exactly what they're going to find
and Link it appropriately
I look at it as developing the next step
for your readers where do you want them
to go what do you want them to do what
resources do you have available to them
how can you structure them so that
they're easily understood and you're
explaining the Final Destination
like I said if you overuse anchor text
you can be downgraded or penalized by
the search engines so what I will tell
you to do is number one avoid
overstuffing anchor content
that means needlessly repeating keywords
in the anchor text don't do that
avoid being redundant meaning don't have
four or five or six links with the same
anchor text going to the same page
that's a clear way of letting search
engines know that you're going overboard
don't just randomly Place links
throughout your text just to get the
link
ask yourself are you really helping the
reader find the information they need
and do it once
and then also avoid extremely overly
promotional words within the linked text
such as best expert cheap number one
those types of things
so a couple examples we can say for
travel advice click here but I would say
here is my travel advice and Link travel
advice rewrite it be creative
if it were easy everyone would be doing
it
but this is where you can write things
in a better way to get the attention of
the reader and position it as a resource
also utilizing your url as the link or
as the anchor text as well for the link
in order to get that click
as I've got it here I would not
recommend that you use that I would
recommend that you avoid that
also the third line the checkout the
best website for iPhones and iPhone
accessories utilizing overly promotional
words is one of those ways that you can
easily get caught by the search engines
now for future considerations when it
comes to Links realize that the majority
of algorithm changes are link based
evaluation refinements because people
are constantly attempting to fool the
search engines and develop a false link
profile
you should work to create high quality
links with high quality content
I wouldn't chase after Poor or low
quality links
now as I've mentioned before there are a
number of tools available for you to
manage and measure your backlinks tools
such as link decks Moz Raven Advanced
Link manager Majestic SEO and then also
you can use your Google analytics as
well however Google analytics only shows
you the visitors that have come from
links and what they've done the basic
functions of Link management software
and there are many other types other
than what are listed here but the first
thing that it does is just provide a
catalog of incoming links from other
domains to your site and your competitor
sites they offer tools for comparison to
see which domains are linking to you
what type of link it is and on which
Pages those links are listed they'll
also report newly acquired links in the
past 30 60 90 days or something similar
to that the purpose of Link management
software is to help you assess high
quality domains versus low quality
domains in terms of importance and
relevance
like I said the first job of a link
management tool is to collect all of
your backlinks you add your domain and
the tools will usually spider the domain
they'll go out into search engines and
go out into many other formats in order
to find and retrace who is linking to
you what page that link is contained
sometimes what text is on that page and
what text is being used in the link they
will catalog all of your incoming links
organize them format them and report
back to you most of these link programs
provide additional filters and
management tools so that you can get
more insights about who is linking to
you how they are linking to you and the
type of site
personally I use linkedex in order to
Monitor and report on my backlinking so
the first report here that I'm showing
out of Link text is that I see the total
amount of incoming links to my domain
this says I have over 2 000 links and
those 2000 links are on about 1 000
domains on average it looks like I have
about two links from every domain that
is linking to me so this is one way that
you start to look at your links number
one the total amount of domains that are
linking to you and then the total amount
of links available this way you can
isolate domains that are linking to you
consistently and also find those that
may not be the best domains or that are
sending a lot of links that are just not
relevant
the next thing I do in analyzing My
Links is to look at the type of Link
meaning the type of site that it's
coming from
this report breaks down the amount of
links coming from blogs news sites
directories forums social sites articles
or resources now it doesn't usually get
all of those links but it does get
enough to give you an idea of how well
you're doing in each channel one of the
things that I do like about this report
is it also has a timeline so I can look
and see when new links have been
acquired and maybe when some links have
been just disappeared that's called
churn and it's normal it's normal
because many times a link is published
on social media and it kind of just goes
away or it's not tracked anymore by your
link management software it can't find
it anymore and so linking is always
Dynamic you are always gaining new links
and losing old links there's going to be
a normal amount of churn
the next report shows me all of the
domains that are linking to me it also
shows me in the next column how many of
those domains are also linking to at
least one competitor and it will list as
many competitors as I have listed in
here if they list to multiple
competitors
it will let me know the influence of
that site or the authority that site is
seen because of the amount of websites
and credibility that Authority has for
that domain it'll also let me know the
keyword relevance how relevant that
website is overall contextually to my
domain and the content that I have
it will also let me know how many pages
on that domain have links to my website
so I can also go through and I can
filter this list by the type of site I
can filter by those domains that are
using anchor text to see how much anchor
text is being used and what type of
anchor text there are many different
ways that you can filter through all of
the domains that are linking to you in
order to get an idea of what's happening
on your domain
what are competitors doing and also the
relevance of those links to your site
now when I say that I can add
competitors this is another type of
report very similar to the one I showed
earlier where I look at my own standing
in the different types of sources of
links such as blogs directories forums
and so on I can also when I add my
competitors look to see how they are
performing in those different areas as
well and so I can compare my link
profile to my competitors
different Industries are going to have
different backlink profiles they might
be more heavily weighted towards blogs
or they might be more heavily weighted
towards forums or social sites in this
way I can look to see if my competitors
are actively link building and how
they're going about it I can see where
maybe they are excelling in one area
that the rest of the competitors are not
so I can compare different strategies I
can also compare different timelines to
see if I am acquiring Links at a faster
rate than my competitors this is very
important if you are a newer business or
a newer website trying to compete
now specifically what I can do is look
at an individual domain in this case
this domain has three pages linking to
me and that domain also links to two of
my competitors
I can look at the specific pages and
what I'm looking at here are Snippets
this should be familiar to you because
what it's showing is the URL of the page
that's linking to my page it shows me
the page title of that page and then in
this report it lets me know if there are
any keywords being used in the link in
the anchor text as well as the number of
links from that page now what this tells
me is that this is most likely a
directory something that is listing all
the different places where you can buy
products because it's most likely the
linking to the domain name seeing that
there are no keywords being used in
Anchor text and also that there are 16
outbound links from that page
that means that it must be a list of
some sort and they are linking not only
to me but most likely to competitors as
well so I can track my Links at the
Domain level and at the page level I can
look to see which Pages might have more
influence or relevance to my content I
can also see the link URL the page title
if any keywords are being used in the
anchor text and also within the context
of how many additional links are leaving
from that page if there are a high
amount of outgoing links on that page
then a link from that page might not be
as valuable since there are so many
links the less links there are coming
out from that page the more it will
benefit my site because I'm getting more
benefit from less links
now also what I'm going to do is compare
the link reports to my analytics I'm
going to go to my analytics because
linking software does not show traffic
it doesn't show how many people are
clicking on the link it only shows who's
linking to you but it does not show
visitor activity analytics will show you
visitor activity to see which domains
are most effective in sending visitors
to your site if you go back to the
primary benefits of linking visitors
branding and business analytics show me
visitors and business it shows me which
domains are sending me visitors and
which of those visitors are becoming
customers
so what I can do is go to Google
analytics look at all the domains that
are referring traffic to my site I can
also click on the domain and see the
destination page that they are linking
to I can see how many visitors are
coming either monthly or annually how
often they're coming back whether
they're new users or repeat users how
long they stay how many pages they View
and how many conversions as a result of
those visits this is a great way to get
a 360 degree view of your linking
because not only do you want links that
will help you rank better you also want
links that will send business and
customers to you as well
building links can take many forms
ideally it is through networks
relationships and marketing that other
websites and users learn about you like
you and recommend you to others
unfortunately there is a lot of bad
outdated and untrustworthy advice to be
found about building links to your
website
in this section I'll present the best
practices as accepted by the omcp
standard
the objectives for this module that
you'll be able to develop a link
building strategy
that you'll understand the value of
different link types
finally you'll be able to find inbound
link opportunities
the first step in building links is to
evaluate what you have
now there are many tools available that
you can utilize to do this for you there
are automated tools that you can get
that will catalog all of the incoming
links to your website
some of them are link decks Moz Raven or
Advanced Link manager there are many
that can do that you may also want to
utilize your analytics as well in order
to find websites that link to you
the first step is evaluating where you
are right now
your incoming links have a significant
impact on your rankings
and you can do a lot of on-page
optimization and see some results
however a lot of Google's algorithm
takes into account links from other high
quality websites
now when you evaluate what you have in
this example I'm showing you a
screenshot from linkedex
link decks catalogs the incoming links
to my website and it groups them into
different areas
the first way it groups them is by high
value or high influence domains
those are websites that link to me that
have a lot of influence not necessarily
in my industry but High influence based
on the amount of people that link to
them as an authority on many different
subjects
the next way that it groups that is
based on relevance
now this is when it looks at the match
of my content versus the content of the
other website
in the first example we can see the
National Library of Medicine
it is a high influence website because
it is a government website with a lot of
information that is cited frequently
because of the amount of other websites
linking to that site it has a high
amount of influence
now based on the website that I am
measuring
there is a lot of keyword relevance
meaning that that National Library of
Medicine site with the government has a
lot of content that's very similar to my
site a lot of the same keywords are
being used
so not only is this website of high
influence it also has a lot of relevance
and that's key when evaluating my
backlinks
I want to look at which websites are
also referring traffic
so while I may have a link from the
National Library of Medicine I want to
look at my analytics and look to see is
it also providing visitors our visitors
following that link to my site and I
also want to look at the quality of
traffic that it produces
do these visitors stay longer than
average
do they convert more than average I want
to look at the quality of traffic based
on the source
next I want to look at the incoming
links from those other websites number
one I want to make sure that the
incoming link from the other site is
both accurate and relevant meaning the
text that is used in the link is it
accurate to the content that will appear
on the page when the visitor clicks that
link
is the content relevant this is
especially relevant if I have updated my
website changed the content or moved
things around
I want to be sure that that incoming
link sends visitors to the appropriate
page and the appropriate information
I also want to ensure that that link is
worded correctly that it uses the right
words that is sending visitors and
setting expectations of the content that
they will see
I may need to contact the website
manager or owner and maybe ask for a
better linked text or a more accurate
page destination
now this requires some interaction with
the owner or manager of another website
and you always want to be respectful of
their time and not demanding that they
make any changes
in some cases the organization may be so
big you may never find the right person
in order to optimize the text or the
destination of that link
you always want to look for accuracy in
cases where your company or website name
is utilized in the link
but also if there is any contact
information such as address phone number
a description of your business and any
content
make sure it's accurate and it all
points to the right place
another way to look for links is to
Simply go to a search engine and start
doing searches
search for your company your business
your company name and look for websites
that may mention you but do not have a
live link to your website
many times your company will be
mentioned or cited but there will not be
a live link you can only find these
through doing searches and seeing which
websites mention you without linking to
you
now this could be an opportunity to get
an Easy Link especially if you can find
some contact information and finding the
right person that could add a link to
your company information
again you'll need to be polite ask for
their help and it will help it if you
can develop the link along with the link
text and send that over
giving them just a quick and easy edit
to be able to add the information
so make it as easy as possible
as an example I've provided a sample
request format
again you want to be polite you want to
be inviting and respectful of their time
and their management
sometimes like I said you may find the
right person that can help you
however the larger the company the more
difficult it will be to make this happen
this just requires your patience
and again being polite and not expecting
the company to do what you are asking
many times this is just a formality and
sometimes companies will act on it so be
sure to approach this with the right
expectations
the next thing I want to look at are
business listings these are the easy
ways to establish links and ensure that
links are where they should be and also
opportunities
look for business directories especially
if your company has a local presence
you can utilize Chamber of Commerce
lists Association lists or local
listings
if they are on websites see if they
offer links that can go to your website
rather than just the list of businesses
that are in the area
even on a larger level you can look for
associations directories or listings
where you can add your business or
double check if your business is there
and always ensure that your business
name address phone number and URL are
correct complete and consistent with
other listings
the next level will require some active
marketing and that's where you search
for opportunities
you can go out and look for other
resource lists within your industry or
directories of businesses within your
industry and you can get a link many
times through membership or submitting
your business as a resource
however you may want to step up your
marketing you can do that by
interviewing your clients seeing if they
might be willing to provide a
testimonial and a link to your website
you may also want to go out and find
other communities online maybe some
social communities that are relevant to
your industry
get involved with those communities fill
out a profile and get involved by
contributing information
by sharing information you'll find that
people like getting information and
they'll respond by linking to your site
another option is to utilize the tool
that you had for indexing your links
from the first step
you can also add your competitors and
you can look at their backlinks you can
look and see which websites and which
domains are linking to your competitors
but you always need to go and see why
what are those other sites linking to
and what is the nature of that link
sometimes it may exclude you from being
able to approach competitors backlinks
and ask them for links
however if they're being linked to by
companies that are simply stating here
are vendors in this space and they are
linking your competitors and you're not
there
then it might make a lot of sense for
you to approach and ask if you can be
listed as well
however be sure that the links to your
competitors are not from a consumer or
customer relationship
in that case it might be out of line for
you to ask for a link
make sure if you approach anyone who's
linking to a competitor and asking for a
link to your site
make sure the context is right and then
it makes sense for them
and that's the ultimate judge of value
does it benefit somebody else to link to
your site
we all know that it will benefit you
but when you present your link request
you need to offer value and a benefit
for others to link to you
so be sure that you present it in a way
that is beneficial
and good for those people that will be
adding the link they're the ones that
have to take the work to do it and
they're also the ones that are adding a
recommendation for you and your business
so as always you need to be considerate
and patient
now the best way to build links is by
creating something that people like and
sharing it
you see the best way to build links is
by creating value through content or
information or entertainment
you see when people like things they
link to it
if they find a study or a white paper or
research that you performed they link to
it
if you post a infographic that explains
something
and it's attractive people link to it
you see that's what's most amazing about
linking
I find that when we put most of our
effort into creating content that people
like
that's what builds the most valuable and
the most relevant links
and so what type of content well you can
create infographics videos top 10 lists
or articles articles with advice or
analysis of Market data or even research
that type of content people love it and
so when you publish it out you utilize
social media to extend the reach and the
visibility of that type of content
and when someone likes it they'll link
to it and recommend it to others
now people also like depending upon your
industry or your business they also like
some personality maybe some humor
people always like expert information
they like the cute this is why pictures
of cats tend to be liked and linked to
more than almost anything else and also
the unexpected if you can inject any of
that into your content that just makes
it more valuable more personable and
again more shareable
by other people and every time someone
shares it it builds a link to your site
you see the best linking is when people
like something
when you create something that people
like and share you might be surprised at
the many opportunities there are
to get links based on your content
I've seen many many blogs based on
cooking fashion Arts Sports music
and when people specialize within a
specific topic they always find an
audience and so anything they publish
builds links
even on certain social media sites such
as Pinterest
people upload pictures on articles and
infographics especially about
landscaping flowers food cars you name
it there is a special interest for
anything and you can develop links from
those social sites to your site
and it can generate traffic
even with a Blog developing articles
that talk about upcoming events new
music Sports whatever it is when you
create content that people like
it takes the longest amount of time to
build content for building links when
you develop your own content that's the
biggest investment you'll make in time
and research and writing and
presentation
however
the result is that when you develop that
content
you will receive the best and highest
quality links and the most valuable
links are going to be to that content
as I mentioned before one high quality
link can be worth more than hundreds or
thousands of low quality links
so my best advice is to create content
that people like that they link to
and that will be high value links that
you'll generate to your site so if you
are looking to become an SEO
professional then look no further than
simply learns post graduate program and
digital marketing gain in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
with this course you will also learn
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and much more unlock a
whole toolbox of skills including SE
ranking HootSuite Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads and
Keyword Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course Link in the
description for more information
optimizing technical elements of a
website such that search engines can
easily crawl and index the web pages is
known as technical SEO
some technical optimizations include
reducing the page loading speed of a web
page to a minimum
submitting sitemaps to search engines
have organized website structure as it
informs search engines about the
essential pages of the website
adding redirections for the deleted URLs
or temporarily moving urls
identify duplicate content and replace
it with unique content before I tell you
how to bring traffic to your website let
me tell you why this is so important
okay why do we want to bring users to
our website I mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored post and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads it's one of the easiest ways to
drive traffic to your website so some of
the options available are search ads
social media ads or display ads so
search ads or ads that are displayed in
the search engine results so when a user
types in a keyword query you want your
ad to show up based on that keyword
query okay so an example is digital
marketing course somebody types in
digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first ad that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you could
see the word add next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
learn is going to pay Google so that's
how search advertising works okay the
next is social so social media marketing
involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness so lots of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image it
could be with a video so in this case
you could see cobrao is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have Tech stats but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content is gone live you could take it
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment or if you're a vlogger
okay so YouTube's a great way to promote
your site by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have Twitter Twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
Industries Beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on Twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can Drive traffic
to your side as guest plus blogging so
most of you already know what blogging
is all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guess post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your blog or website so it
exposes to you to targeted traffic so if
you're going to guest blog guest blog on
a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the Right audience okay you
can expand your personal Network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for serves
because it generates backlinks so serps
search engine ranking Pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging isn't a way
to generate some backlinks to your site
and in effect that's going to help you
get your pages ranked higher because
Google is going to recognize the
relationship from one blog to your blog
and build up your relevancy so some
other benefits here to guest blogging is
you can grow your social media following
because you can then promote that on
social media that you're guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
Authority okay because when you're guest
blogging and you have recognition on
that guest blog if it's a popular blog
then it's going to help your domain and
Page Authority for SEO and then the end
result is going to improve your backlink
score so a lot of benefits to guest
blogging to me at the end of the day
it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
that traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so getting
yourself out there nobody knows who your
brand is and they know who the thought
leaders are and they see you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's responsive and what
do we mean by responsive well we mean
does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
and larges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arrange
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices into the images text and
everything else align just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your web side is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
those fonts make sure they look good and
then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness on mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build a community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that their
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's a
about identifying your brand with other
people okay and identify people who
identify with your brand and messaging
and talking to them as if they're part
of your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could it be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I.E post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your causes what your
mission statement is what your Services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or Cora or Mania sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand Equity you have some thought and
some knowledge touch on the specific
topic and subject so it just puts you in
a better light when you can respond and
be active on these different platforms
okay let's turn our attention to search
engine optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability and visibility on
search engines and obviously that comes
with advantages one of those advantages
is obviously more traffic to the site
search is still King in terms of volumes
of people using search on a daily basis
so you have a great opportunity to be
found it also builds trust and
credibility because still a majority of
the people who do a search click on an
organic search list in and so if you're
found organically and you're ranked
number one then chance chances are
somebody's going to click on your
listing and it provides increased
engagement in traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement an
engagement is something you define it
could be again a download of a document
or the clicking on the play button of a
video or or submitting a form or signing
up for a newsletter or calling these are
all forms of Engagement so the the
amount of traffic you drive from organic
search to your website is only going to
improve engagement okay so you can also
provide and improve user experience and
what do we mean by that well if you're
getting lots of traffic from organic
search you have a really good
opportunity to do a b testing and when
you do a b testing you can improve user
experience meaning you're showing one
variation against the other from people
coming from organic search and so this
is helpful in that you know if you're
running an a b t test the variation has
a chance to improve or outperform the
original and if it outperforms the
original you're improving user
experience and then it helps Target
quality traffic so SEO to me or all
search is the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway you're
you're addressing what they're looking
for so somebody's looking for a pair of
red women's Nike shoes the 2019 model
and you have that particular product to
offer well you have a chance of showing
up via organic search somebody types in
you know women's red Nike shoes size
whatever at the year 2019 model then of
course they're gonna probably likely
click on your listing because you have
what they're looking for and and that
goes with any keyword any industry any
business any segment any type of product
you're selling so again you have a
chance to really be visible for what
people are looking for and so that's the
beauty of search engine optimization you
have a really good opportunity here to
meet people halfway to drive quality
traffic to get them to enjoy a good user
experience all the while generating
engagement and along with SEO we want to
be able to build backlinks so SEO is a
two-pronged approach meaning you have
two strategies in one on page and off
page and so off page involves
backlinking so backlinks are just links
that direct users from other websites to
your own website so with that inherently
it's going to drive traffic qualify
traffic to your website because if
somebody's on a relevant website that's
linking to yours and they click on that
link and go to your website it's likely
going to be qualified meaning they're
going to be relevant and so backlinking
because it's an off-page strategy why
isn't an off-page SEO strategy because
if Google crawls that other site that
has a link to you then that's going to
give you credit because Google say hey
this site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust the site so by Google trusting
your site it's going to improve your
organ ranking and with the organic
rankings being improved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're going to follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get index
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credits from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simply
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if I have 100 people
land on my home page and only one person
went to another page and the other 99
left the site then that's a 99 bounce
rate so by putting internal links in
place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older posts so again when we say
older post we're really referring to
blog posts so if you have a relevant
blog post and you're writing in new blog
posts then link the two together if it's
relevant link it I don't you know
regardless of how old it is you know you
want to show Google that these older
block was just because they were written
a year ago doesn't mean they're outdated
and old-fashioned okay or useless you
want to keep them alive by linking to
them so to me that's a good strategy for
internal linking link to older blog
posts you know show people you're an
industry expert you've been doing this
for a while and then you have lots of
content to share okay so the longer you
can keep somebody on your website the
more likely it is they're going to
engage and convert and some other
inherent benefits improves pagerank so
what we mean by pagerank is simply just
a rank that Google gives pages so the
more internal linking you have the
better off you are and then it helps
spread link juice across websites and
what we mean by link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so there are usually three or
longer keywords in a phrase okay so long
tail keywords really nowadays account
for most web searches people really take
the time to even post questions as a
search query it's a likely somebody it's
unlikely somebody's going to go into
search and just type in the word shoes
they might type in red shoes but that's
unlikely but they're probably going to
type in is you know red Nike running
shoes 2019 or some variation of that
okay that's a long tail keyword and some
of the advantages of using long tail
keywords to be found for are less
competition so if you're using broad
keywords like red shoes then who doesn't
want to be found for Red Shoes well you
don't necessarily you don't want to be
found for red shoes because it's too
broad you don't know what type of shoes
somebody's looking for you just know
they're looking for Red Shoes it could
be running shoes it could be work shoes
it could be you know boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords help narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused a keyword is the
less competition is going to have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does a search
for that and that's a long tail keyword
and they click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is it brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into cells why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing a specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it could be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually depending on the the email
provider you're using really is a flat
fee so just really depends on how how
many emails you're sending or how how
many people you're sending the email to
as well so but email generally tends to
be more cost effective than other forms
of marketing so look at the email
content provider you're using and just
get a sense of what they charge but if
you look at it and do a comparison email
generally is cheaper than say doing
pay-per-click because with pay-per-click
you're paying for each click okay so
that could be expensive depending on the
keywords so email marketing is also time
saving okay meaning it's a one-time
thing and done so once you send the
email it's just a matter of you know
watching and looking at the metrics and
learning what's going on so you don't
make the same mistakes again but it is
time conducive meaning you send out one
email and that's it with pay-per-click
you're constantly measuring and managing
the campaigns and it provides real-time
marketing so when you do send the email
more than likely majority of the people
on day one or the day you send the email
I are going to be able to view it open
it click on some of the links and
convert so that's normally what happens
in email majority of the people open it
on day one and it kind of tails off from
there so think about it as real time so
when you send that email and if you have
a thousand people on your email
recipient list break it up send the
first 500 first with a different subject
line and then you can see the data come
in and if you don't see the good results
from the subject line or the body of the
email or you know the page they're going
to then make adjustments before you send
the other email to the next 500. so
that's a great thing about emails you
can break up the email into two groups
the first group and then the second
group with different subject lines and
you can probably send them a little bit
of time apart that way you can learn
from the first email because with email
you are generally going to get results
right away okay within the first 24
hours so that's a great thing about
email okay so the other other thing
about email it's less intrusive so
normally people who are going to get the
email are the ones who sign up for the
email so they're almost expecting your
email so when they get your email again
as long as you're not sending an email
on a daily basis normally most companies
send it monthly or bi-weekly it's not
going to be as intrusive okay and then
it also helps build credibility increase
visibility and brand awareness meaning
you're going to build your brand in that
email you're going to put content in
that email that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonials in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you can track bracket
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can and that's the beauty of
email marketing okay let's move away
from email marketing to webinars so
webinars great method for Effective
social media promotion it's a great way
to bring traffic to your website so why
do we recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you you know you can even set up a
webinar and another platform but promote
it on social media and if you're
pronouning something on social media
you're probably promoting it to people
who are already following you or like
you and so that's what we mean by direct
contact with your target group so you're
going to be able to create a webinar and
talk directly to that group and that's
going to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently interesting to maybe a larger
group of people you can promote that on
social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
going to check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Vimeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves the ROI so always
think video there's plenty of video
software out there that you can leverage
and the great thing about video two is
hey most people are using mobile phones
these days smartphones and so video
works just as well on mobile as it does
on desktop so keep that in mind you know
video is going to be engaging regardless
of what device somebody uses and then of
course if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then it's chances
are they're going to share that
particular video which is going to bode
well for your brand and traffic okay so
video if somebody likes a video it's
very easy to share video especially from
a mobile phone so YouTube just makes it
so easy to share or like or subscribe to
a channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well a
Content aggregators like Reddit that
provides a great platform for you to
post your content so that's what a
Content aggregate is really a site like
Reddit or medium or quora where you
could post content to a large number of
people okay so with Reddit people are
either going to upvote it or downvote it
so the more upvotes you get are thumbs
up or likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case around across the board whether
it's a social post or blog post make
sure the content's unique professional
and interesting and then if you do say
put something on medium or you do put
something on quora and it is
professional and interesting and thought
provoking then people are going to react
to it and then that again could lead to
traffic but even if it doesn't lead to
traffic it helps build brand awareness
so if you have content just like videos
leverage it put the content out there
okay and when you put content out there
it's only gonna especially if it's good
content put it's going to put you in a
good light so don't be afraid to share
your content on the likes of Reddit or
medium or core or some of these other
content aggregator websites because good
things are only going to happen and
again referral traffic SEO brand
awareness conversions so all these are
inherent benefits of just sharing your
content okay and then finally we want to
learn from analytics okay so what do I
mean learning from analytics so there
are plenty of analytics platforms out
there one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so I have to do is
just go to Google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and voila they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
are they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you can
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they come in from
organic search it is so Google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by Page by Language
by city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to say so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's is a segment
and you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you can see how they're performing
okay so Anna there are a lot of benefits
to Google analytics definitely wants to
take advantage of segmenting in Google
analytics you could look at your
competition so there's a benchmarking
report the great thing about Google
analytics you can also look at content
and how your content is performing once
somebody lands on your website are they
what page are they spending time on what
page are they engaging on the most okay
what pages have the highest bounce rate
or the lowest time on page so you can
really determine what pages work best
and then of course the end result in
analyzing all this data is you want to
be able to fine-tune your website so
take advantage of the data that Google
analytics or any other analytics
platform is giving you by learning once
you learn what's going on with your
website you can make adjustments to your
website to improve user experience okay
so we went over a lot of different ways
to drive traffic okay you can
incorporate all this to your website
immediately so if you are looking to
become an SEO professional then look no
further then simply learn Sports
graduate program in digital marketing
gain in-depth knowledge of search engine
optimization with this course you will
also learn content marketing web
analytics keyword management and
research website optimization and much
more unlock a whole toolbox of skills
including SE ranking HootSuite Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads and Keyword Planner don't
miss out on this opportunity Find the
course Link in the description for more
information research let's talk about
that keyword research for a website with
shoes and it doesn't really matter what
particular product you have if you need
to rank number one on Google it all
starts with the keywords as I mentioned
before and so in this example if you
have a website where you sell shoes for
kids you're going to want to be found
for certain keywords so the obvious
keyword here would be shoes for kids
well every key word that you target has
search volume associated with it so that
means when we talk about search volume
we're talking about how many people on
average type in that keyword or related
keyword on google.com or Google search
and there's always an average number of
searches associated with every keyword
and we call that search volume how much
search volume so obviously if we're
going to Target a keyword we want to
have as much volume as possible however
there's always going to be competition
for those keywords meaning there's
always going to be other websites who
want to rank number one on Google for
the same keywords and we call that
competition or difficulty so for every
keyword you're going to have volume them
and you're going to have competition or
difficulty and the difficulty ranges as
well depending on the tool you use and
we'll get into that in a minute but
search volume is how much on average
people are typing in that keyword or
close variance of that keyword and the
difficulty is measured in terms of how
many other websites are trying to rank
for the same keyword and so ideally when
it comes to keyword research we want to
find that nice balance we want high
volume and we want low competition but
at the same time we want to focus on
keywords that are highly relevant to our
business so if we're selling shoes for
kids and shoes for kids is highly
relevant has high volume and low
competition then that's a keyword we
want to Target so we always want to
focus in on those three areas so there's
always a trade-off with keywords so
shoes for kids might have high volume
but also might have high competition or
difficulty if we look for another
keyword that's just as relevant for
example shoes for children it may still
have high search volume but the
competition or the difficulty may be
lower and if that's the case then that
may be a better keyword for us to Target
instead of something highly competitive
like shoes for kids we can focus on
another relevant keyword like shoes for
children with just as much volume and
lower competition and the reason why we
want lower competition is because we
want to be able to rank for that keyword
so the higher the competition the harder
it is for us to rank number one on
Google for that keyword and so the whole
idea be on keyword research is analyzing
and choosing the best keywords so we
want to identify a list of keywords that
are always relevant we want to choose
the keyword that your competitors are
ranking for and we want to use
third-party tools to choose keywords to
identify which can keywords have low
competition and what keywords have high
search volume so one thing to take into
consideration when you're doing keyword
research is that the longer the key word
phrase or in other words long tail
keywords or keywords with three keywords
in the phrase or more you're going to
always have less competition but there's
always a trade-off with long tail
keywords meaning the longer the keyword
phrase there's going to be less volume
but the trade-off is less competition
and so what we want to do is we want to
brainstorm some ideas and find those
relevant keywords so let's look at an
example here so if we go to Google ads
so Google ads has a toe call Keyword
Planner and let's just say I have a a
website where I'm selling dried fix and
if I'm selling dry figs I want people to
buy these dried figs however in order to
attract them I want to be able to show
them that hey we have a a bunch of
recipes and if I show you a bunch of
recipes where you can use dried figs
maybe you'll buy these dried figs to use
in these recipes and so we're going to
look for keywords related to bread
recipes because if we can optimize for
our recipes page for bread then that
will attract an audience who wants to
make bread and use dried figs with those
bread recipes so that's the example I'm
going to give here and so if I look at
the Keyword Planner and Google ads if I
just type in bread recipes what Google
is going to do is they're going to give
me an average monthly search volume so I
can see the average monthly search
volume here is sixty thousand five
hundred and so in order to do keyword
research what I would recommend is keep
a spreadsheet and so the idea behind the
spreadsheet is to document the volume
and the competition you're getting for
certain keywords so if I go into a
spreadsheet here my theme of keywords is
bread recipes my keyword is bread
recipes and my volume therefore is going
to be sixty thousand five hundred
however if I go back into Google's
Keyword Planner Google's telling me that
competition is low so that's great I
want high volume I want low competition
but how low is low so we want to be
careful so if we're going to put in
numbers into a spreadsheet we want to
figure out what that competition really
is for the keyword bread recipes so if I
go to Google and just type in bread
recipes I'm going to be able to see
771 billion results for the keyword
bread recipes now is 771 billion are
real competition maybe maybe not what we
want to do is put in a syntax and we
want to put in the syntax all in title
and then colon space and then our
keyword and the reason why we do that in
search is because we want to be able to
identify the true competitive number or
the true number of websites or trying to
rank for bread recipes and if we put in
the syntax all entitled colon and then
our keyword bread recipes we'll be able
to see that there are 998
000 results that's a lot lower than 771
billion so that means that 998
000 sites or listings have the keyword
bread recipes in the title tag and the
title tag is what shows up in the search
engine results and so if I look down and
scroll down here I can see bread recipes
or every one of these title tags so
title tag is an important element to
rank number one on Google and we'll talk
about that in a few minutes but if we
understand that they're 998 000 results
with bread recipes in the title tag then
this tells us that those are the web
websites who are trying to rank number
one on Google for that keyword and
therefore those are the websites we need
to jump over in order for our website to
rank number one on Google and so
therefore I'm going to put in 998
000 in my spreadsheet as the competitive
number and so now I could see for the
keyword bread recipes I have 60 500 and
if my competition is 998 000 then my Kei
or keyword Effectiveness index or in
other words the ratio of volume to
competition is six percent so that's
nothing more than volume divided by
competition so that tells me that my Kei
or my ratio between volume competition
is six percent so remember we want more
volume than we want competition so
anytime you do a keyword research you're
going to find a number of different
relevant keywords so if I go back into
Google's Keyword Planner if I typed in
bread recipes you could see that Google
is going to give me a number of
different keywords related to bread
recipes let's just say I have another
keyword that I want to think about
optimizing for being ranked on Google
for and that's banana bread recipe very
similar keyword as bread recipes except
it's a little longer tail now if I type
in banana bread recipe and Google's
Keyword Planner now I can see the
average monthly search volume has
actually gone up it's 368
000. I can also see the competition is
low so those are good signs so now I can
see 368
000 I'm going to go ahead and put that
in my spreadsheet now I'm gonna go into
Google I'm gonna put in my syntax all in
title I'm going to put in banana bread
recipe I'm going to hit enter and now I
can see I have 233
000 results with the keyword banana
bread recipe to pay in the title tag so
if I look at the title tags I can see
banana bread recipe banana bread recipe
banana bread recipe on all the listings
in the Google search results so that
tells me I have 233
000 results that I have to jump over in
order to rank number one on Google so
I'm going to put 233
000 in my spreadsheet now I can see my
Kei or my volume to competition ratio is
157 158 and so to me that's a lot better
number to work with or in other words
that's a lot better keyword because it's
just as relevant and it has a higher
ratio of volume to competition so
therefore banana bread recipe is going
to be a better keyword to optimize for
in order to rank number one on Google so
that's the whole idea behind keyword
research you want to brainstorm ideas as
there are plenty of tools out there so
the tool I recommend is Google ads
Keyword Planner Google is going to give
you how much search volume they're going
to tell you the competition but then
you're going to go into Google search
you're going to use the syntax all in
title to get a more accurate read on the
actual competitive number and so to find
out how keywords that your competitors
are ranking for you can use those
keyword tools that I mentioned another
tool that I use is moss so Moz if you go
to moz.com they have a tool called
keyword Explorer so if we just type in
the keyword for example bread recipes
it's going to be able to tell us how
much volume and the difficulty so you
can use other tools at your disposal
figure out the volume and the difficulty
there are plenty of tools out there but
the one thing I would just make sure is
you use everything at your disposal so
you can use social social media to find
the most shared article for a particular
topic or keyword like bread recipes you
could check other platforms that have a
lot of shared content like reading and
Cora where you can ask people about
certain topics using keywords to figure
out how much competition or volume there
might be you could stay up to date on
industry news to get an idea of what
types of keywords are trending but when
it comes to keywords and keyword
research remember for every web page we
want to be able to pick two keywords we
want a primary and secondary keyword so
when we do keyword research and we enter
all our keywords into our spreadsheet we
want to be able to have a number of
different keywords in this case we're
focusing on the theme bread recipes we
want to have different keywords because
we want to be able to choose a primary
keyword and a secondary keyword because
we want to be able to focus on multiple
keywords for each page because we don't
want to put necessarily all our eggs in
one basket meaning we won't want to put
all our emphasis just on one keyword to
rank for we want multiple keywords to
try and rank for so the primary keyword
can Define the nature of our business
the secondary keyword could be just
highly relevant to our keyword at the
end of the day we want to choose
multiple keywords to try and rank on
Google for that page so for example we
have a Blog and we're using ice cream
recipes and we're blogging about ice
cream recipes we can have the primary
keyword that is about ice cream recipes
or homemade ice cream recipes we're
going to always want to find out what
the volume and the competition is our
secondary keyword could be built around
other similar keywords like low-fat ice
cream recipes or fat free ice cream
recipes or low-fat homemade ice cream
recipes those are complementary keywords
just like our bread recipes and banana
bread recipe so one thing we want to do
when we do keyword research is we want
to be able to Target one keyword per
content when you can Target many we want
to be able to Target multiple keywords
not necessarily Target one keyword and
so we want to be able to Cluster
keywords so we don't want to Target just
one we want to Target multiple keywords
per page and when we talk about
clustering if we go back to our keyword
research what we're doing is we're
clustering a bunch of keywords under the
theme bread recipes and so by looking at
the volume looking at the competition
looking at the Kei we can choose
different keywords for our page and
that's what we mean by clustering we
want to Cluster keywords into a Content
frame so why Target only one keyword per
content when we can Target many because
we don't want to put all our eggs in one
basket we don't want to Target just one
keyword we want to Target many and so
that means clustering your keywords into
a theme and choosing multiple keywords
for that particular page and when we do
that we have a better opportunity to
rank high on Google Search and the whole
idea behind ranking high on Google
Search is we can get the volume so if we
know we're ranked number one on Google
search for bread recipes or banana bread
recipe we know we stand a chance of
getting a majority of the volume
associated with that keyword and if we
can get the volume and get the traffic
then we can get the conversions so let's
move on to high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on Google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on you know page four
of Google Google and it's that blog with
ice cream recipes and if it's just
content for the sake of content is not
really informative then it's not
necessarily going to get good engagement
in the eyes of Google you know they want
to rank content that's very informative
it's very fresh it's exciting to read
it's interesting it's going to have good
engagement so if it's a recipe or an
article about any topic if it's the
content is just non-informative then
you're not going to get good engagement
and when you don't get good engagement
if people don't stay on the site to
engage in the content and they just
leave the website after landing on the
page causing a bounce then the content
is just going to continue to fall down
the rankings and we want to prevent that
we want to move up the rankings we want
to be number one on Google we don't
necessarily want to fall in the rankings
for our content so content is a key
driver in being able to rank one on
Google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like Facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that Community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summertime and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signal animals is it good
is it not good do we like this content
are we giving it a thumbs up are we
going to want to follow it are we going
to want to share it and so if you share
content that you feel is engaging on
social platforms then it's going to be
engaging and it's likely going to cause
an increase in engagement for example a
decrease in balance and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on Google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
Google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do I make you
know a bread or how do I make a specific
type of bread or how do I make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talk about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and that
will help you do quick research on you
know keywords and Trends and whatnot so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below I'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question and that's the
whole idea behind content content is not
just a fill a page it's to really
fulfill users requirements that's when
you get good engagement so if somebody's
typing in something on Google and
they're looking for an answer your
content should answer that question but
we also want to make the content
readable so in other words you know
write for your audience don't impress
anybody with very high vocabulary type
words that somebody doesn't necessarily
know the meaning of don't use jargon
don't use a street language for example
use everyday common language that's just
easily digestible when your audience is
reading and then we want to keep that
content organized and so when we mean
organized we want to use headers and
subheaders you know break your content
into paragraphs keep the flow organized
if we can keep the flow organized then
it's going to be easier for somebody to
read and then it's okay to add resources
especially resources from credible sites
so if you can incorporate those
resources in there then it's just going
to add The credibility to your content
let the audience know that hey I've done
my research on this topic and this is
what this person has to say about it
this person who seems to be credible
okay so it only adds value to your
content so these are all tips to
Remember When creating content and then
the one one important tip here is we
want to use white hat techniques and
when we say white hat techniques that
means you know if we've chosen keywords
that are going to answer somebody's
question we don't want to stuff those
keywords into the content we want the
content to be naturally written so when
we say opt for wide hacked techniques
that's what we mean write the content
naturally keep it organized keep it
readable include third-party sources and
make sure it answers a question so there
are different types of content so
there's content where you just write
words to install text based you could
also use an infographic infographic is
simply just a graphic that visualizes
exactly what you're trying to explain
for example if we want to write an
article about how to write good engaging
content we don't necessarily have to
write all that out as a text we can
create an infographic so for example
here's an infographic on 20 any
effective ways to basically not bore
your readers but write engaging content
so you could see this is an infographic
it's all graphically laid out so
infographics tend to be easier to
understand because they're visual
they're easy for the end user to
comprehend because there's generally no
jargon it's usually images that are
portraying the point of what you're
trying to get across and so it tends to
break it up the monotony of just text
it's more visually appealing and it's
laid out and organized so you can see
this infographic has 20 different steps
or rules and they lay those out all here
in this infographic and the great thing
I like about infographics is you could
you could share them on social media you
can re-engage them as a post you could
save them from really any social
platform so infographics tend to tell a
better story and versus say just writing
text you can use video and images so you
don't necessarily have to lay it all out
in an infographic you can certainly
insert a video or an image into your
content especially if it's a blog post
if it's a blog post then sometimes video
and image is on its own tell the story
you don't necessarily need text to go
ahead and tell your story a video or an
image as they say tells a thousand words
and so images and videos are great to
use in a blog post so using different
forms of content you know you always
want to review your content when a user
dwells on your web page for a longer
time Google will tend to think okay this
person's engaged so we're going to rank
that favorable so if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out accounts in a way that somebody
doesn't necessarily understand so be
creative in the types of content you use
so longer engaging content tends to bode
well with search engines so this is
according to HubSpot so the more word
count you use the more word you use the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again there's best practices we just
went over but the key is you know if you
have longer more engaging content then
it's going to bode better for you on
search engines so a couple of steps to
create high quality content so you want
to begin with the comprehensive
introduction so always introduce your
content remember the content should be
relevant to the keywords so if you're
choosing keywords and your keyword
research think about answering that
question if somebody's typing in bread
recipes maybe they're looking for banana
bread recipes how to make the best
banana bread or how to make banana bread
using dried figs we want to be able to
align our content with that keyword
naturally you want to create a title
that's worthy that's click worthy so
remember if you're in Google search and
you're doing search for something simple
like bread recipes we want to make
something that's going to be you know
engaging for somebody to click on like
easy perfect yeast bread or easy crusty
French bread or something that's going
to be engaging you know the best bread
recipes or how to make the best homemade
bread you know something that's going to
draw somebody's attention to the title
of that blog post so so we want to
include LSI keywords so what I mean by
LSI keywords in your content we mean you
know long tail keywords make it natural
headings and subheadings should consist
of keywords and variants so if you're
writing headers and subheaders include
the keyword in there and that way the
content always stays relevant to the
audience okay shorten your sentences and
paragraphs so don't write long
paragraphs remember we want to break
this up we want to make it easier for
the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to pen the
image with text so that way if the image
doesn't load then at least the alt text
will load so we can incorporate call out
boxes and more importantly we want to
update our content regularly so we
always want to get the best recipe out
there if it's banana bread or different
ways to Crepe banana bread or always
just coming up with ways to update the
content so we want to keep our content
our blog post fresh and then we want to
include a CTA call to action if we
include a call to action then that's
going going to keep somebody engaged and
have them act on your content so these
are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
BuzzFeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweaks and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012. again a lot of
Engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we could see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because says listen you know it's
engaging content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
contents updated regularly it's engaging
and it includes sources from high
Authority websites some do's and don'ts
on the content so take into account the
best practices I mentioned about
creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content I.E in the form of infographic
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the BuzzFeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some Do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
Adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraph graphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content okay so now that we've talked
about how
quality content in order to get your
pages ranked high on Google search let's
turn our attention to optimizing on-page
elements and discuss some website level
factors that are both going to help you
rank high on Google search so let's just
do an overview of what we're talking
about when we talk about on-page
elements and website level factors so
optimizing on page elements include a
number of different things but primarily
we're going to focus in on meta tags
also known as meta description tags
header tags also known as title tags and
URLs so those are just some of the
on-page elements we want to be able to
optimize using relevant keywords in
order to rank on Google search we also
want to take a look at some website
factors that will affect our ranking on
Google search they include website
architecture having a secure web website
having a site map and taking a look at
page speed so all of those are some of
the website factors we need to take into
account in order to rank high on Google
search so title tag and meta description
together are considered meta tags so
both play an important role in ranking
high on Google so we want to be able to
write unique title and descriptions for
each page on our website when I say
unique that means a title In The Meta
description need to be different for
every page on the website and so if
you're not quite sure what a title tag
in a meta description tag is if you go
to search and just type in any
particular search query the title tag is
what's going to show up here in bold and
then the description is going to show up
below it below the URL and that's going
to describe the page so both of these
meta tags are important because it
describes what your pay is all about and
that's what Google uses in the search
results pages so we want to be able to
pay attention to the length of our meta
tags so if we go back to our search
results Pages met title tags are
generally 60 65 characters meta
description tags are generally 160
characters so anything really longer
than that then what's going to happen is
the meta description tag or the title
tag will get trunk at it and so if we
look here for example we could see all
of the title tags here fit the 65
character limit but if you run over the
character count on meta description then
Google is going to truncate the copy so
you want to stay within your parameters
in order to avoid getting your content
trunk at it and so the other thing when
we're writing title meta description
tags we want to minimize keyword
repetition so if we're optimizing for
key word we don't want to necessarily
just plug that keyword into the title
tag and meta description multiple times
we want to make sure our title tags and
meta descriptions are naturally written
so if somebody's typing for banana bread
recipe with dried figs you know we want
to have a nice title tag and a
description that is going to get
somebody to respond based on their need
and so we definitely want to avoid
keyword repetition but we want to be
able to use that keyword in the title
tag because if you remember from the
earlier segment when we did the all in
title syntax to find out exactly how
many competitors were using that
particular keyword well we obviously
want to use that keyword in the title
tag because again the title tag is an
important factor when it comes to search
engine results so we want to use the
keyword but we want to avoid stuffing or
using it repetitively in our title tag
and our meta description we want the
title tag tag and The Meta description
to describe the page sound natural but
also be engaging because the point is we
want people to click on our link and go
to our website from search engines so
title tags with numbers tend to results
and higher click-through rates this is
according to mods so for example if you
just put in a title tag that says learn
digital marketing well that may work but
if you put a number in there like five
easy ways to learn digital marketing
that might get somebody to click on your
link and go to your website so having
questions in your meta tags can also
increase your click-through rate for
example if you just put learn the
importance of first page rankings not
too bad but again generic but if you put
it into the formal question how to rank
number one on Google it's more action
oriented it's gonna get somebody to
resonate with the question that they
have and that may be their query how to
rank number one on Google and and so
these techniques will help you get
higher click-through rates and so
according to backlinko title tag with a
keyword can improve site ranking so
remember we want to include that keyword
in the title tag even though we only
have 65 characters we want to include
that keyword but we want to avoid
stuffing the keyword in there we want to
again make the title tag action oriented
maybe with a number maybe as a question
with the keyword in there once naturally
not easy to do but that's the beauty of
SEO if you can follow these best
practices and write a good title tag
then the chances of you improving in
your search results are going to be
greater so having only one H1 tag in
your post is going to be good so
remember when somebody clicks on a link
so let's say they do find a title tag
engaging and they click on this this
link and care and they go to that
website you know you want to start out
with having that particular H1 Tech
because the H1 tag especially with the
keyword in it is going to signal to
Google hey we're organizing our page and
because it's an H1 tag it's important
we're structuring the page according to
best practices so having only one H1 tag
in your post is definitely helpful
having multiple tags H tags in your post
help organize the page a lot better so
we want to add that targeted keyword in
that tag and your tatter tag should be
relevant to the content so if we go back
to our example of the using dried figs
with banana breads well the title says
California fake banana bread and
remember the last segment when we're
talking about high quality content well
look no further than including a video
into our content so not only will this
video help keep the engagement high but
it breaks up the monotony of the page
and it's from a third party source so it
adds credibility to the page so adding a
video based on the last segment of high
quality content definitely helps with
ranking high on Google search so
following hierarchical structure that
means putting those H tags in there H2
tags help break up the content and we
want to avoid repetition of H1 tags on
your different web pages of your site
meaning don't just put the same H1 tag
with the same keyword in it and keeping
it blase we want to make those H1 tags
exciting to read but also used
appropriately to break up the content so
remember all white hat techniques we
want to avoid hidden tags we want to
avoid stuffing keywords we want things
to be natural we don't want things to be
forced and your H1 tag should be 20 to
70 characters don't make long H1 tags if
we go back to our page example a short
sweet tag here California fig banana
bread it's relevant to the content it's
short sweet it breaks up the monotony of
the content and more importantly and
again any content you have on the page
should always answer the user's intent
remember people are using search to
answer questions find information our
content should be able to answer that
for them so according to John Moeller
senior webmaster Trends Analyst at
Google header tags would definitely help
Google for rankings in the search
results so we want to use header tags so
when it comes to URLs we want to use
hyphens and avoid underscores so if we
look at this URL here this uses hyphens
fig and banana bread so it's all broken
up with hyphens that's a best practice
remember canonical URLs a canonical URL
signals to Google this is the original
content so we want to use original
content and if you have multiple sources
of content out there on say different
websites we want to use a canonical tag
to signal to Google this is the original
content please Index this content and
that doesn't hurt to use a favicon URL
meaning a small icon and helps to break
up the monotony and help your URL stand
out we can add targeted keywords in the
URL so again looking at the URL here I
can see we're using targeted keyword as
part of the URL structure Fagan banana
bread and that is the H1 tag is fake
banana bread so it's all consistent and
it flows naturally URLs that are no
longer existing then we want to be able
to set up a redirect for those URLs
meaning a 301 redirect is a server
response for Google that says Hey Google
this page is no longer available but it
we permanently redirected it to this
page which is now available so that's
what a 301 redirect does it helps signal
to Google and all the other search
engines that if the page is no longer
there that's fine you're just going to
go to this page this is the page that's
permanently there now and another thing
we want to do here is if you have mobile
URLs you want to include those in the
site map and we're going to hit on that
in just a minute but all urls should be
mobile friendly as well as desktop
friendly meaning take into account those
best practices keep your URLs short use
hyphens put the keyword in that URL and
make it easy to understand want to avoid
capital letters in the URLs the URLs are
case sensitive so go lower case you
should always go lowercase from the URL
readable URLs again the rule of thumb
here is if you understand what the URL
is then Google is going to understand
what the URL is so the shorter the URL
the easier it is to read the easier it
is to read the better chance you have to
rank high on Google search so according
to back link to URLs that are shorter
definitely definitely help you rank so
we want to be able to shorten those URLs
keep them short and sweet don't make
them long and unreadable so those are
some on optimized ways or on-page
elements that help you optimize now we
want to look at some website level
factors that will help you optimize and
rank high on Google search so good site
structure provides better crawling for
search engine Bots and what do we mean
by that well we mean having your site
organized in a fashion that Google's
going to be able to find all the pages
so what do we mean by that create a
logical hierarchy structure so if you're
selling shoes you know you're going to
have a home page break the structure up
into men's shoes women's shoes
Children's Shoes then under men's shoes
you can have it by brand it could be
Nike Puma Adidas on the women's side it
could be Nike Puma Adidas on the child
side it could be Nike Puma Adidas and so
you want to keep the structure flow and
a hierarchy do we want to balance the
amount of subcategories with in each
category so the men's if it has Nike
Puma Adidas the women should have Nike
Puma Adidas and so you want to code your
site navigation and CSS or HTML meaning
we want to be able to use something that
Google's going to be able to index so
most sites are built in HTML and that's
what Google likes to index they like to
index something that they could take
back to their servers and then more
importantly build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking so
internal links mean that if you're on a
site you should have natural lengths
pointing to other pages on your website
so to keep the flow going we don't want
to have unnatural inbound links you
always want to have natural internal
lengths to keep the flow of the user
going from one page to the other so here
I could see as an example all the
ingredients in this recipe well this has
an internal link to another page on our
site and this happens to link to a page
where somebody can buy the ingredient so
it's a natural internal link so John
Doherty of Credo has claimed that one of
the biggest changes that he can make in
fixing the Credo website is architecture
so for example in Credo John Doherty has
increased the organic sessions by 74 in
Pages by per session by 41 just by
changing the site architecture so you'd
be surprised by changing the site
architecture what that will do to
engagement and so let's turn our
attention to secure versus non-secure so
what we mean by that is securing your
site we want to make it sure that
compliant with certain protocols and so
if we go back here we can see that this
particular site is compliant it is
secure https means it has a sec cure
license meaning the site is secure so
Google likes secure versus non-secure so
non-secure would be HTTP so we want
https as our protocol and what that
means is just enabling SSL certificates
and that means when you enable an SSL
certificate that means your domain or
your protocol is going to be turned to
https so Google prefers sites that are
secure versus non-secure so if you use
hsts as a protocol that adds an extra
layer of security over the https and
hsts prevents cookie hijacking so adding
multiple layers of security always helps
in my opinion if you have an HTTP
website a non-secure website you should
look into buying an SSL certificate
getting your sites flipped over to https
because what's going to happen is you're
your rail structure is going to change
when your url structure changes Google's
going to recognize that because it's
going to index your site and when they
index your site they're going to see
those secure URLs and that's going to
work favorably in your favor and help
you rank higher on Google search so
websites using secure or https have a
higher chance of ranking higher so https
is a ranking signal because Google
indexes those pages so let's also talk
about site Maps so sitemap is one of the
most important ways to improve your
website ranking why well because
sitemaps are a way to organize all your
URLs into one file so we're basically
going to prioritize all our web pages in
a sitemap so if you go to any particular
website and you type in sitemap XML
you're likely going to see all the pages
on your website so usually the site map
is located in the root Direct directory
so if I type in sitemap.xml I'm going to
be able to see all the pages in my root
directory and I can also prioritize them
I can also alert Google as to how often
they change and every page is going to
have a date stamp associated with it so
Google can actually see how often it
changes so remember we want our content
to be updated frequently so content's
not updated frequently or it's not fresh
then Google's gonna see that size that
date stamp that last modification down
so we want to be able to make sure
content's updated frequently we want to
let Google know that we change it
frequently and we want to be able to
prioritize our Pages let Google know hey
these pages are important to us so all
that can be set up in a site map we want
to be able to add canonical versions of
URLs in the site map so we want to be
able to add all our original URLs in our
sitemap and so we always want to build
Dynamic URLs site maps for larger
websites and what I mean by Dynamic URLs
that means that if I look at this side
map and we're always adding content
let's just say in the form of a Blog
well guess what we want those pages to
be added to the sitemap as they're
published so as we add pages to the blog
or to the site then they should
automatically be added to the sitemap
and so in effect what's going to happen
is we're going to be able to see the
site map grow with more URLs when the
sitemap grows with more URLs then that
means then Google's going to index more
pages they're going to index more fresh
pages so they're going to be able to get
those pages that are just published
quicker so that's the whole idea behind
Dynamic sitemaps is we want to be able
to capture all the URLs just as they're
published and we want to be able to
maintain our sitemaps and so I would
always recommend a dynamic sitemap but
you can always create your own sitemap
just by going to a tool called XML
sitemaps so if I just type in XML
sitemaps into Google search here I can
see XML sitemaps generator and I can be
able if I have a small website just
create a free and simple site map on my
own when XML sitemaps creates it or your
platform creates a dynamic sitemap
either way the sitemaps going to sit in
the root directory and then what we want
to do in turn is let Google know where
that sitemap is so in search console we
want to be able to submit the sitemap so
you're going to add the site map you're
going to let Google know where it is it
should be in the root directory and it
should be called sitemap.xml and when
you do that Google's going to be able to
take those URLs and index them so we
could see we submitted 528 URLs Google
index 521 so one thing about URLs here
is when we create a site map we're
putting all your URLs in there we do not
add no index URLs in your site map when
what that means is that any URL we don't
want Google to index we're just going to
exclude from the sitemap okay so we want
Google to take all the URLs we want
indexed and put them in the sitemap so
according to edgy using sitemaps for SEO
can increase your website's visibility
and help you get indexed why because
what you're in effect doing is taking
all your URLs that you want indexed
you're telling Google how often they're
modified you're telling Google which
ones are important and you're submitting
that to Google and so Google's going to
be able to take all these URLs quicker
index them quicker and when they're
indexed quicker you can get ranked
quicker and when you get ranked quicker
you can get traffic quicker so that's
the whole idea behind sitemaps so let's
turn our attention to page speed now so
when the last factors for our website
besides architecture making it secure
and adding sitemaps is we want to take a
look at how quick our Pages load here
are some tips in order to optimize page
speed because ideally the quicker a page
loads the more engaged the user is going
to be if it takes a longer time for the
page to load all the elements of that
page then what's going to happen is the
user is going to get impatient maybe
leave the website all together or go to
another page and so we want to be able
to optimize images so any image that's
of large size in terms of megabytes we
want to be able to optimize that
compress the image so that's one way to
speed up page speed we want to use a
simple website design you know HTML with
CSS or cascading style sheets just a
simple design with simple a hierarchy
and website navigation structure so
nothing fancy nothing complex just a
simple website design with optimized
images we want to leverage browser
caching and we want to upgrade the
server response time meaning all your
files are sitting on the server so when
somebody it goes to web page the server
is serving up all of those files the
images the text Etc and so we want the
server to respond as quick as possible
so when it comes to page speed we can
look at the factors affecting page speed
and Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I go under behavior
and I go under site speed and I go to
overview I'm going to be able to see
what my average load time is for my site
and ideally we want our pages to load as
quick as possible so that means anything
under four seconds anything four seconds
or higher and it's likely the end user
is going to leave the page there's a
correlation BP between page load time
and bounce rate and so what Google
actually does is give you speed
suggestions so if we do have a page that
loads slow we can just go to speed
suggestions in Google analytics and we
go to speed suggestions then Google's
going to be able to tell us hey okay
this particular page load fast this
potato page loads slow and if it loaded
slow why is it loading slow so here we
could see the home page of the example
is loading on average of seven seconds
well if we look here they're going to
give us some suggestions so if I click
on this page speed suggestions it's
going to load a report and a tool called
page speed insights and basically what
it's then going to do after it's done
running is it's going to tell me all the
ways in which I can optimize my pages
not only for desktop but also for mobile
so here I can see for desktop or for
mobile I can look at some ways in which
I can optimize it to increase page speed
for example sizing my images properly
server response time reducing my server
response time avoiding multiple page
redirects so there's a lot of
opportunities that we can do to speed up
page load time and all that's found in
page speed insights and all that's found
within Google analytics so remember
optimizing code minimizing redirects
optimizing your images upgrading your
server response and all of those are
factors and so again you can go into
analytics page speed insights and you
can see exactly what Google is
recognizing as what's lowering or
slowing down your page load time so
Google takes site speed as one of the
most important ranking factors why
because they're going to rank Pages not
only with high quality content that are
relevant to the keyword queries but they
want those pages to have a good user
experience so somebody clicks on the
page then the user should be able to see
that content fairly quickly and so
that's why it's such an important factor
so the quicker your pages load the
chances of you ranking higher are going
to be better so according to web
performance today Walmart as an example
experience decline in conversions so
what they did was looked at their page
speed and when they looked at their page
speed you'd be surprised what that did
just increasing it from one to four
seconds or decreasing it basically
increased conversion so there's always
going to be a correlation between how
quick a page loads and how engaged the
user is because if it's users engaged
they're going to stay on the site and if
they stay on the site then their chances
of converting are going to be higher so
just even one to two seconds increase
and Page low is low time will make a
world of difference in terms of
Engagement and conversions let's turn
our attention to off-site engagement so
previously we talked about on-page
elements and website factors that are
fact our rankings for search results but
we also need to turn our attention away
from our website meaning what we do on
our website and turn our attention what
we can do for our website off our
website and onto other websites so
that's off-site engagement and so let's
look get an example so that ice cream
recipes blog so we did everything we
possibly could we updated The Meta tags
the title tag The Meta description we
added H1 tags we've made sure the site
architecture was sound we submitted a
site map we we made sure the page load
was good and fast so we did all the
things we're supposed to do on our web
page but we're still not ranking well
what do we need to do well we need to
turn our attention away from our website
into other websites we call this off
site or off-page SEO and we need to
basically generate links from high
quality sites back to our site so if
we've done everything we can on our own
website and we're still not ranking
where we want to be well then we need to
turn our attention to other websites and
so if we turn our attention other
websites and other websites that are
relevant other websites that are of
quality uh other websites that have high
domain Authority then we're going to see
an increase in rankings so it's just a
matter of getting quality links from
quality websites that are relevant
that's what's going to move the needle
on search after we've taken care of all
the on-page elements so more backlinks
from high domain Authority results in
higher rankings SEO is a combination
between what we do on our website
meaning optimizing the page and making
sure our website has good site
architecture and follows the best
practices in terms of site maps and Page
load then we need to turn our attention
to the backlinking to improve our domain
Authority so according to backlinko
analysis off-site engagement is one of
the most important elements for ranking
number one in Google so you can't just
focus your attention on updating the
title tag and making sure the pages load
fast you have have to turn your
attention as well to getting back
lengths from high quality sites that's
off-site engagement and so gaining links
back links from multiple domains is
vital it's vital because they bring
referring traffic to your site they
bring credibility to your site but more
importantly Google is going to recognize
the relationship between these sites and
your website and if these sites that
have backlinks or links pointing to your
site and if they're of high quality then
we call that passing link shoes so it's
going to bring quality to you in terms
of organic search so if we look at an
example if I do a search for banana
bread recipe they're 241 billion results
for banana bread recipe Why did this
particular page from Simply Recipes rank
number one well we can turn our
attention to Moz and Maz has a report
called link Explorer and so Moz link
Explorer report helps us identify our
own page Authority our own domain
Authority and how many links we have
from other quality websites so if I put
that particular URL into link Explorer
and notice the URL here is short even
though it uses an underscore when it
should use a hyphen it's still ranked
number one and why because off page
elements help this page rank number one
why their page Authority out of 100 is
58. their domain Authority out of 100 is
82 and what does that mean well that
means that they have a lot of good links
from other domains of high quality they
have 824 linking domains to this one
domain they have 3600 inbound links and
they're ranking for a lot of different
keywords so if we scroll down we're
going to be able to see kind of a
breakout the quality of websites that
are linking to them so they have 19
domains with a domain authority of 91 to
100 linking to them they have 15 domains
between the range of 81 and 90. so what
does that tell me between 15 and 19
that's 34 particular domains that are
very high quality linking to it and so
we could see the breakout of the linking
domains we could see the top file links
to the site and we can see the page
Authority so the link Explorer report
gives us an overview of what pages are
linking to ours and it also gives us an
idea of what our own page Authority and
domain Authority are because domain
Authority and Page Authority both need
to be high in order for us to rank on
Google search in order for it to get
high we need links from high quality
sites so that's the whole idea behind
off-site engagement so some of the
offsite engagement prints are influencer
marketing meaning is there somebody out
there on social who has a huge following
but not only do they have a huge phone
but are they relevant to our product for
example Usain Bolt who's a famous
Sprinter if we're selling shoes and
we're selling Nike shoes maybe Usain
Bolt can reference us on Twitter or
Facebook that's influencer marketing
getting people to influencing people to
buy our product we can engage with
audiences on multiple social media
platforms like Facebook and Twitter
meaning if we're running a promotion on
those running shoes then we can promote
that on Facebook okay we can promote
that on Twitter we can also bookmark our
webpage on popular bookmarking sites
like StumbleUpon we can also put our
content on discussion forums like Reddit
we can join High PR quality q a sites
excuse me and post answers to questions
related to business like quora.com so we
can engage in sharing our content and
answering questions so there's lots of
ways to get links to your website if you
have a blog post as an example you can
make sure that maybe that content is
shared on a similar blog post so if you
have an ice cream recipe blog post well
maybe you can look at a dessert blog
post and share your content on that
particular blog post and have a back
link pointing from that blog post to
yours as an example and you can
reciprocate so the whole idea of content
is sharing the content but at the same
time of sharing it you're producing
backlinks and backlinks help domain
Authority so not only did I help domain
Authority but they improve the search
rankings so in Google's eyes the higher
your domain Authority higher the page
Authority in Google's eyes that means
your page is important it's credible
herbal and we're going to improve it in
the search engine rankings it increases
brand visibility if we have our content
on a highly engageable website a highly
popular website or blog it's not it's
going to lift our brand visibility if we
have Usain Bolt who's very famous
Sprinter do some influence in marketing
for us then that's going to increase our
brand visibility so anytime we can
associate with something that has some
influence or some clout or high domain
Authority then it's only going to
increase our brand awareness and
visibility so again it's going to
increase our domain Authority because of
the association of passing link juice
from one domain to another it's going to
then as a result increase referral
traffic because if we're on a high
quality website that gets a lot of
traffic then the chances of some of that
traffic going our site is going to be
great and again it improves The
credibility and Trust of our website and
that's what we want we want Google to
trust us and a way to build trust is is
by associating our website with other
websites of high equal or higher quality
so when we talk about off-site
engagement we want to do some guest post
on relevant websites so if you have that
ice cream blog go to another blog like
the dessert blog and do a guest post so
not only that will that improve your
brand awareness but it'll generate a
backlink and maybe drive some referral
traffic you can participate in forms and
blog discussions like core.com or Reddit
get your content out there start a
discussion about a specific topic to
engage users build brand awareness and
generate that backlink you can always
you know put your your site on a
directory like Yelp for example or Yahoo
directory you could prefer testimonial
link building meaning if you serve
products or offer up a service well
somebody could provide a testimony on
their website or you can just earn back
links from relevant authoritative the
web pages like we mentioned quora or
Wikipedia or there's plenty out there so
the idea is to associate yourself with
high quality websites but do it
naturally you don't want to force
anything so if you're selling a specific
service or you're selling a specific
product look for like mining services or
products that complement what you do and
that'll create the natural environment
natural ecosystem that will eventually
give you the benefits that you need to
rank higher in the search results pages
so we don't want to purchase any links
we don't want to cloak content we don't
want to just inject links on sites that
aren't relevant we don't want to just
have site-wide links all over the place
pointing to the same page and we
certainly don't want to be on low
quality websites or directories it's all
about quality not quantity with off-site
engagement so having an off-site
engagement complements what you do on
your website for on-site together both
of those efforts will get you higher
search engine results so if if you are
looking to become an SEO professional
then look no further then simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing gain in-depth knowledge of
search engine optimization with this
course you will also learn content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and much more unlock a
whole toolbox of skills including SE
ranking HootSuite Facebook Instagram
LinkedIn YouTube Twitter Google ads and
Keyword Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity Find the course Link in the
description for more information is your
web not ranking as you thought it would
are there too many competitions out
there
is it getting difficult to capture
relevant audiences
are the solutions suggested too
expensive
do not worry in this video you will get
easy solutions to all your questions as
we have come up with a list of top 10
SEO tools that anyone can use
and the best part is you need not to
spend a single penny on these tools Yes
you heard it right they are free of cost
and are very useful for anyone who wants
to start an online business or
struggling to improve reach so let's
jump right into the list
but before we do kindly subscribe to our
Channel simply learn and hit the Bell
icon to never miss on such interesting
and useful videos
to carry your best SEO practices the
first free tool on our list is the
Keyword Planner
Keyword Planner is a free keyword
research tool provided by Google
proper keyword research is important as
it increases the possibility to rank
well on the search result Pages the
Keyword Planner will help to discover
new keywords estimate monthly searches a
keyword has
get the cost of ads for the keyword
you're looking for
and help to organize keywords let's
understand how to use Google Keyword
Planner
open your AdWords account
now
go to the tools section and select
Keyword Planner
now you can either add a keyword to get
new insights or upload a CSV file to get
search volumes of already known keywords
let's see how it works
click on discover new keywords
from here you can change the location
enter the key phrase for which you need
keyword insights
click on get results
here you can see all the keyword ideas
related to your keyword phrase
now to get the search volumes of already
known keywords go to the Keyword Planner
and click on get search volume and
forecast
now upload your CSV file from here
here you will get search volumes for all
the keywords
other similar tools with free trials
include
keyword tool dot IO and keyword
generator by RFS
to know trending ideas you can use
Google Trends whereas to get title ideas
you can use the answer the public tool
which is free now let's see the next
tool in the bucket
Google search console Google search
console is a free webmaster tool
provided by Google
it is important to timely monitor your
website and make it error free this is
where Google search console comes into
the picture
it helps businesses to Monitor and
maintain their website's presence in
Google search results some features of
Google Search console includes
getting confirmation that Google search
engine can crawl your website
fix the problems in page indexing sends
Pages for re-indexing can view Google
search traffic data
records the number of times your website
appears in the search results
records the search queries for which
website appears in the search result
shows the list of sites linking to you
and many more
let's Now understand how to use Google
search console
here the total Impressions suggests that
number of times your website appears in
the Google search results
whereas the total clicks suggest that
number of times your website is clicked
from the Google search result page
from the coverage section
you will get to know all the errors
occurred during the crawling
we recommend you to try your Hands-On
tools like Bing webmaster tool
and RFS which is free for website owners
next up we have the used SEO plugin
used SEO plugin helps in improving your
search results ranking it helps you free
as well as a paid version as a beginner
you can quickly check the free version
it has an inbuilt feature that
automatically carries out SEO analysis
and readability analysis and
automatically adds structured data let's
take a quick look at SEO plugin
from here you can add SEO title
from here you can edit the slug slug is
the part of URL you can add the
necessary keyword here
in The Meta description section you can
add the meta description
which all together looks like this
where this part is your slug the keyword
you want to add in your page should be
added in the Focus key phrase section
the SEO analysis section
shows the SEO improvements in your
content
now moving towards the readability
analysis
readability analysis shows Improvement
in the textual content of the page
if both the indicators are green then
your SEO and readability both are good
to go
for yoast SEO we have covered the
significant features and now we will
understand one of the essential SEO
tools Google Analytics
website tracking plays an important role
in SEO it helps in understanding the
user behavior on your website Google
analytics is an Analytics tool used for
tracking a website
the standard version of Google analytics
is free
we can integrate Google analytics with
Google ads
the main features of Google analytics
include tracking session duration of
users pages per session and tracking
website traffic and bounce rate of users
let's take a quick tour of Google
Analytics
here you can see reports of users for
last 7 days
now go to the reports section in the
dashboard
foreign
you can reset the time span to get the
desired data from here
go to retention
where you can see the number of new
users and the number of returning users
to your website
to know the data on monetization
go to the monetization section
here you can see the monetization data
for the selected time span
we will understand Google analytics
features and how it works in the
upcoming videos in detail moving ahead
with the next tool which is
small SEO tools puljanism checker
duplicate content is hated by search
engines if not taken seriously this
could hurt your search rankings
the plagiarism Checker detects duplicate
data in your content and shows its
source
you need to open this plagiarism checker
here you can add your content manually
after adding your content manually you
just need to undergo a verification
and click on check plagiarism
and here we get the results the content
is hundred percent unique
in case if we get any duplicate content
we can check the sources from here
as our content is unique we are not
getting any results here
in case if you don't want to enter your
content manually you can upload document
file from here
note that this Checker checks for the
top thousand words of your content so in
case of lengthy content you can break
the content and then check for its
uniqueness in case you don't want to
purchase the pro version moreover you
can also add a page URL to check the
uniqueness of the content the page has
over here
and follow the same process by clicking
on the checkpleasing button
the plagiarism Checker by grammarly is
also one of the free tools used for
checking uniqueness in the content
the next tool that we have in our bucket
is the paid speed insights
per the data provided by Google the
bounce rate increases to 32 percent as
the page load speed increases from 1 to
3 seconds
page speed insights is the paid speed
check tool
page speed insights is used to test the
speed of a web page and it is a free
service offered by Google developers
results of paid speed insights show what
real users are experiencing about your
page on mobile devices and desktops to
understand how to use it let's go to
paid speed insights and select the URL
of the website for which you want to
undergo the check
enter the URL and click on analyze
button
now choose whether you wish to undergo a
check for mobile or desktop device here
I'll select a desktop device
just in few seconds you will get the
required results
another tool that we can use is
tools.pingdom.com which has free as well
as paid versions
moving forward to the next magic tool
which is SCM Rush
to grow your business it is essential to
keep an eye on what your competitors are
doing this will help you to understand
their strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitor
analysis sem Rush is the competitor
analysis tool
that gives a complete walkthrough the
competitors data like keywords
backlinks top performing content
campaigns
Etc
it has free as well as paid versions you
can access free trials by simply signing
up on semrush.com
so let's take a quick overview of how it
works
login to your sem Rush account
here enter the URL of your competitor
here you can choose a geographical
location for which the analysis is to be
performed
by adding URL you get all the competitor
data
here I have added sem Rush as a
competitor so we are getting so many
details of sem Rush The Organic keywords
the organic traffic paid keywords paid
traffic referral domains and Authority
score
we can add a competitor as well from
here
now here you can see the data of both
sem rush and RFS
other than sem rush you can use spyfu
which has some free daily trials now let
me tell you about an excellent auditing
tool
which is screaming frog
dear Learners it is essential to know
how your website is performing and for
this you need to carry out frequent
website audits
screaming frog is a website auditing
tool that works similar to web crawlers
it has free as well as paid versions
some features of free version include
finding broken links errors and
redirects analyzing page title and
metadata
href Lang attributes auditing finding
duplicate content
Etc with a crawl limit of 500 urls
let's know more about it go to screaming
frog
now
from here download the tool on your
system
check various resources provided
on how to learn the tool from here
another alternative tool you can use for
auditing is seability where you can
enter the URL and get the audit reports
moving further with another free tool
which is rf's backlink checker
gaining high quality backlinks is an
essential factor for SEO ranking as it
shows the trust of other websites in
your content moreover it helps in
building the authority of your website
with the help of backlink Checker you
get the data of all the websites linking
to your website rf's backlink Checker
shows the data of top 100 backlinks top
5 anchors and top 5 Pages including
total number of backlinks and referring
domains in its free version
let's have a quick look at the tool
here let's take example of wikipedia.com
so here we are checking backlinks for
wikipedia.com
now click on check back link
here we got details of backlinks for
wikipedia.com
alternatives to rf's backlink Checker
are SCM Rush backlink Analytics tool and
seability
by signing up with these tools you will
get some free trials for your site last
but not the least let's know about the
mobile SEO tool which is mobile friendly
test
studies show that in year 2020 60 of
traffic was through mobile devices thus
it is essential to keep your website
mobile friendly as well
here is when the mobile friendly test
comes into action
it helps to check if your website is
mobile friendly or not go to mobile
friendly test
and enter the URL of your website
suppose I enter your www.wikipedia
.com
now click on test URL
here you get the results
we can see that the pages mobile
friendly
to check more details you can navigate
to your search console account
well if you think we are done for today
then then keep watching this video as we
have two bonus tools for you
so here comes the first one
the separator
search results vary with mobile devices
also your brand ranking May differ from
country to Country
to get reports on this separator will be
your all-time companion it it shows how
search results May differ for mobile
devices or locations
let's see how it works
go to separator
now
let's fill in the required fields
let's select the location
let's run the live test
and here we get the results
that's it daily you can run three free
live tests isn't this amazing
without taking a minute let's know about
the second bonus tool
which is
the rich results test
you must have seen these kinds of search
results on search pages
let's dive deep into it
yes these type of results are known as
Rich results
to check whether your site is optimized
for Rich results
go to Rich results test
and add the URL of your website
let's add the URL of Simply learn
now click on test URL
complete the verification
and check the report
so here we can see that simply learns
website is eligible for Google searches
Rich results
to monitor Rich results for your
complete website you can easily navigate
to your search console account
here we wrap up with basics of SEO if
you like this video hit the like button
and consider subscribing to our Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn till then keep
watching keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here